and then
yeah
hey morning everyone so we are still
live from Panama Gabriel sitting here
next to me so let's start the day today
we're gonna go through price action on
AMC on gme guys as every day we have
some uh big big day today coming we have
the 25th of March expiry on gme the
number of options is absolutely massive
on this expiry so we're gonna have a
look at that we're gonna have a look at
what it can mean in terms of price
action today but I can already tell you
that it can be it can be very wild
because of the huge gamut is here so
we're gonna go through that I'm gonna
explain again what it means how it works
and what kind of moves we can expect
today so let's start right now with uh
we're gonna start with gme
let's start with Jimmy guys
hey morning okay go to I'm gonna check
that later guys we have 10 minutes left
so I want to do quickly the technical
analysis of Jimmy and AMC so first Jimmy
so um yesterday we were trading rather
flatish uh we we ended ended up the day
up one percent uh despite a small uh
pullback a small pullback to the 130
area
um that was our first support that was
here bam let me put it in green okay the
volume was low so it's like a little
pose in the rally so like I said this is
totally normal we always have this kind
of small consolidation small Corrections
in any healthy move up so this is pretty
good to me especially that it happened
before the 25th of March which is today
which is a massive expiry day guys so
I'm gonna go through that very soon so
first 130 support we came back close to
the 140 level which was our
first resistance it's not a strong
resistance because once again to know if
your resistance is strong enough you
need to check how many reactions you had
and uh when it was the move recent past
is the more important so here as you can
see we had some reactions but nothing
that massive okay so then
uh what we can expect today is to go
test this resistance again so let me
zoom in quickly let's go on a shorter
time frame bam so
uh let's go to 30 minutes time frame
because we've seen that the 20 uh period
moving average was acting as support So
as you can see here then we went through
it it didn't act very strongly as
resistance let's be honest uh but we
still went through it came back we
tested it so it was acting very well as
support
but it didn't act very well as
resistance so right now we don't know if
it's still a good moving average to
follow but as you can see and this is
the reason why you always need to have
different moving average averages on
your charts because
um sometimes it's the 20 sometimes it's
going to be the 50 sometimes the 200 you
don't know which time frame but that
Gonna Give You reactions so you need to
go from a short time frame to bigger one
um or to zoom in it's better actually
from a larger time frame than to zoom in
and check which moving averages are
giving you good reactions and here we
can see that the 50 day moving average
is giving us good reactions so maybe
we're gonna set up a trade here around
137 we're gonna see
um so the momentum is still bullish guys
here
definitely let's see what is happening
today but the global market is opening
up so that's pretty good let's have a
look at AMC right now and yeah just to
conclude the first resistance we have on
Jimmy is
147. I said 140 140 is rather the pivot
uh pivot Points around which we are
hovering but the resistance is created
by you know the recent highs that we had
so 140 748 you know the closing candles
that were here uh on Tuesday and the
real resistance guys is at 160. so let's
see if we are able to go test it today
this would be amazing and we would
um I would be very exciting to see what
is going to happen around this
resistance trap your first rejection uh
and then then we're gonna see if we are
able to get back to it with some volume
this is what we want to see today
oh okay hey bro salute solution
all right let's do MC guys
and then of course you can ask me
questions if you want so AMC daily time
frame same thing a little bit as Jimmy
um so this is the situation we had this
uh
this move down that started in November
21 and we were looking for some uh
signal that is saying that this move
down is complete it was pretty hard we
had a lot of fake signals uh in the in
this whole move down
um and this signal we had on Monday is
definitely the best one we got for some
time uh because it involved a much
bigger volume than everything else
traded in the past six months okay so
volume is one of the most important
indicators especially uh when it comes
to stocks like AMC or gme because you
guys know that the volume is making uh
is what makes people discuss this the
more people involved the more we're
going to talk about it the more we talk
about it the more people are gonna come
to the trade so this is how it works so
volume is extremely important on those
stocks and here once again it's the
biggest volumes we had since August 24th
so then after this move we managed to
stay high which is very good we don't
like to see the price action rejected
you know after such a strong move
um but let's compare this I have
something cool to show you guys
we are wondering if we are ready to
squeeze right we are wondering if we can
go to I don't know 100 maybe in a month
or in a few weeks all right this is the
question everybody has uh you guys even
asking if we can go to 100 000 all right
I don't know maybe you know technically
it's possible it seems a bit
um too far as a Target but uh fine so
here what we can do is we add this kind
of event that happened uh actually not
that long ago in May 21 and I'm sure
everybody remembers that this was the um
the closest
situation that we had the situation that
is the closest to a squeeze right to me
this was a squeeze at least a gamma
squeeze uh I'm sure shots covered here
of course not all of them because some
of them they have just more limits so
they can handle a big loss but uh here
everybody was buying you know they were
natural buyers and there were shots
covering I think so we can compare this
situation that started in May 21 and I
was covering AMC at that time and you
can check my video guys I was calling
for it of course and
I pretty much found the levels before
they happened and the the targets and
the pullback levels how did they do that
I use Elliot waves combined with
Fibonacci so here the first thing that
we can assume of course every move is
different but we can assume that we're
going to have the same kind of structure
if we get the same kind of moves why
because we have the same players that
are involved in the trade that are gonna
probably trade roughly the same way so
look at that guys okay I prepared this
chart for you
look at this move up that we had here
that started on the 6th of May how what
do you see we see one two three four
five candles going up
yes bro you were there when I gave the
targets cool man I hope you took
advantage of this and and I'm gonna try
guys once again to guide you as good as
I can but everybody knows that it's
technically impossible to predict what
the market will do but it's we have many
tools we have you know we have a lot of
past information so we can try to you
know find some areas where potentially
we can have some rejections and
especially structure to move up and a
move up is usually
um created by five waves and look here
so we have these five first candles
going up okay grounding higher at the
beginning exactly like here one two
three four five all right so we have the
same beginning of the structure then we
add a massive move up okay so here we
had six actually one is hidden here so
this time we have six candles going
higher then a massive move up here we
have five then a massive move up then it
got followed by three more candles three
more bullish candles for now we have one
that is very bullish so this is for now
stronger than that
um we are having a small tool back just
like here and let's see if today we make
a stronger move or not let's see what's
going to happen but I mean a scenario
close to that is not uh impossible at
all so this would be a first wave I'm
here giving you guys the bullish case
because
of course anything can happen but it's
looking very impulsive because of the
volume because of the strong moves that
go through some major resistance as and
after a long correction involving a lot
of volume so
whenever you have this kind of event you
can consider that the move that just
happened is the beginning of a longer
term move okay so we don't know for sure
but we can assume that so it's it's a
first wave all right so then you put a
first wave let's see where the first
wave can go but just looking at the past
I think that 22 or 25 is a good Target
then we're gonna have probably a second
wave pullback then a third wave four and
five okay so once again as you guys know
um
um I'm cautious because for now we don't
have the signals everywhere that things
are coming back on the global market but
start we start to have some good news
happening on bitcoin for example uh we
have some breakouts happening uh on uh
ethereum as well on a lot of altcoins uh
Etc
um I was checking some of them today but
we're gonna go through that again but we
have some things happening here we have
some brackets happening on different
meme stocks as well on uh Tigre on sndl
uh we got bbig Milan that we're uh
ripping as well so we can see that and
the global market is doing good okay not
amazingly good but good enough
so we can see that we are in a situation
where things start to be hot again but
after a long time like we had where we
were correcting you know bears are a
thing still sitting just above and
waiting you know for Bulls to die and
you know there's gonna be one more fight
it's for now there is no capitulation of
bats to me
even if we saw some strong volume traded
uh on green days which means that Bears
lost money uh but I think they're still
uh they are not ready to let it go fully
I'm talking roughly about everything
guys okay because the situation is not
perfect we have a lot of reason to think
that uh especially regarding the global
market
that things are not stabilized yet so uh
for this reason I think that we need
maybe more time but let's
uh even if I think we we need more time
let's try to make the more bullish
scenario that we can get okay so it's it
would be something that developed in one
two three four five so in this situation
where the first wave can go first we can
zoom in even more because the first wave
should be an Impulse so it should
develop in five waves as well so I'm
gonna hourly time frame and as you can
see for now we didn't really consolidate
after this first wave so this is the
reason why I believe this is one move up
one first wave and that is gonna correct
a little bit at some point okay so let's
try here to make same thing some area 12
counting inside that so one two
three four five so it's possible that we
get something like that guys okay
once again I'm doing here the bullish
case because today is a big day and I
believe something nice can happen so
let's see
okay let me put that in minor
all right
okay once again uh when you start to do
to draw your Elliott waves it's of
course Very subjective there is no good
answer but what is important is to get a
very strong move with a lot of volume in
the third wave so I always start from
that and third waves remember that guys
they often go through major levels so
here definitely the 16.5 level was the
resistance that got broken here the
download shopping trendline that we had
of this whole move down and it's where
the more volume has been traded so this
is a good start for us to to think it's
a it's a third wave so if this is the
third here we have one two quite obvious
and so yesterday was the first wave so I
don't know if the false wave is complete
or not false wave usually develop in uh
three waves so here it's unclear once
again when you start to do some aliative
counting on the hourly time frame guys
you're gonna have a lot of noise you're
gonna have a lot of uh uncertainty it's
very you know it's not an exact sense at
all but it just gives some rough
indications uh Bam Bam Bam so here ABC
maybe we are doing an ABC so let's see
right now we are pulling back a little
bit 18 19.8 uh to me the first the
support area is still around 18 19
something like that so I don't know
exactly what's going to happen today but
maybe one more leg down just a little
bit
or maybe it's done already once again
it's very hard to do something
notification on the short term
but let's see if we're able to get this
fifth wave if we do
it would look very good because it would
follow exactly guys uh the theory the
theories that moves up developing five
waves with a massive impulse in the
third wave evolving a lot of volume uh
then we we're probably gonna start to
see some um you know bearish uh signals
on the short term something like lower
volume on the way up so now we have the
lower volume on the way down this is not
bearish this is bullish guys this means
that the move up is healthy
um but if we have this fixed wave
wheeze for example a bearish Divergence
and a lower volume and we arrive close
to the 25 level this would start to not
be easy but quite clear of what is
happening probably we're gonna then get
rejected come back to the 22 level
something like this and here we would
very likely have a bullish reaction so
we are not there yet I'm just making one
scenario of course there are other
scenarios this is the bullish case guys
uh but let's be honest things look good
for now
so let's see if we're able uh to you
know to reach those levels
uh we of course today gonna try to set
up some trades this is the purpose guys
of this live training um of these lives
where I try also to show you a bit uh
what kind of Trades we can do on the
short term
okay hey Scott what's up bro hey Gary
how are you guys
Okay so
uh bam bam bam what else can we say I'm
trying to find some short-term
resistances on AMC as well for now Bulls
you know Bulls are strong guys we can
see the price action is they're not
holding well
I'm trying to think where we can buy
some shares guys because once again uh
we're gonna try to get in some trades
yesterday we tried to buy Bitcoin uh I
had some permission issues I think it's
because I called my broker this morning
it's because my account is based in Hong
Kong and you guys know that China has
some issues with you know crypto the
cryptocurrency market
so my order couldn't get placed but
anyway it wouldn't have been executed
we're gonna go to that soon I want to
stay a little bit on a mcgme
so like I said this is the bullish case
let me zoom out a little bit guys go
back on the forward time frame okay this
is how it would be looking so once again
guys it's very possible that this
doesn't happen I really want to you know
be clear on that uh you know when you do
technical analysis in in this kind of
environment you can only make some
assumption and
um
and try to guess how things will happen
but you know you never know exactly how
the market will react and sometimes you
know you have some moves that are
totally unpredictable all right so just
keep that in mind and but it's still
interesting to you know stick to the
theory and see how things could happen
if the theory is followed so this is
what could happen if the theory was
followed it's too early guys to use some
Fibonacci projections because as you
know Fibonacci projections are very
useful to know where the force wave will
pull back once we have one two three all
right then the force the bottom of the
fourth wave is kind of predictable and
the top of the fifth is predictable as
well this is what I've done guys back in
June 21 when I gave you guys the levels
almost perfectly so I hope I will be
able to do that again guys
um so let's see what's going to happen
here
uh bam bam bam we're gonna wait hero
same same thing as usual guys we're
gonna wait for some consideration some
some trading pattern to develop for now
awesome obvious support all right 18
points uh seven is an obvious support so
if we get there of course we're gonna
buy some shares uh for now we have
here's some consideration forming as you
can see just below uh the 20.6
resistance level and once again guys you
can see I have this level for a very
long time and surprisingly the price
action is contained just below uh the
issue here is to set up a trade is that
we have this right uh this move that
went through this level uh got rejected
at 22 get got back to it so all of this
area
makes a breakout above the 20.6 level
nuts uh a good I would say setup to
enter so we're gonna wait here I don't
think I don't see anything kind of
obvious to to but to to do some trades
uh let's check gme quickly guys
awesome so Jimmy yeah you see I'm
talking too much and here we wanted to
set up a trade we didn't uh and it it uh
it got it reacted perfectly on the
50-day moving average and 20-day moving
average let's see if it can get back to
it
but this moving average is strong uh the
price action is doing great
uh let me let me put some chess guys
here
now it's moving
okay so it's going to be around 140
I want to make sure for now what I don't
like no there's nothing I don't like you
see I'm just checking you know whenever
you buy on a support area you don't want
to buy when you can see some early
bearish signs early very signs are lower
volume on the way up uh momentum down on
the way up here on the way up it's the
only even here the momentum was going
higher and the volume
the volume was higher as well so you see
we don't have anything bearish on Jimmy
so buying here is a good
opportunity so let's say 140 so let me
put here just 20 shares
okay
so you see today the p l is rather
flatish
for now okay so we buy 20 shares
140 okay so we place this order
okay so first order placed unfortunately
guys as you see we I discussed that just
at the beginning but I was on AMC and
Jimmy went quickly here and bounced so
we missed the straight but guys it's
always like that when you do when you
trade especially day trading you have
many opportunities some of them are good
some of them are not good you're gonna
miss some good ones you're gonna take
some bad ones are you gonna make some
money lose some money you need to be
prepared for all of that many things are
happening so you just need to stay
focused and you know take what comes to
you and just observe and wait for the
press action to give you signals to
getting some trades or exit some
positions you know try to know who is in
control here Bulls are killed in control
uh so what else can we have okay I want
to go through
um hey Patrick what's up bro
the first five waves is it close to 30.
so in the scenario I did once again
what we can do here we can try to
predict where the fifth wave would go if
we have this fix we're developing why
because we have already one two three
four all right and
once again uh Fibonacci and Elliot wave
is a technique that works better guys on
the four hours and daily time frame I'm
here doing it on the hourly time frame
it can still give good results so let's
check let's have some fun okay so as you
guys remember I'm sure you know how to
get this target you measure one plus
three applied to the bottom of the
fourth
and we get our targets
so the levels are
open six one eight one two one one two
one one six one eight okay so here it
would be 25 28 to the three now the
theory is also saying that whenever the
third wave is extended then usually the
fifth wave is uh smaller and if you have
a third wave that is not that big then
the fifth wave is usually extended here
we are rather in the situation where the
third wave is extended right because the
third wave was absolutely massive uh
okay so in this situation we usually
have a fifth wave that goes to the 0.618
which is 25 24.6
so this would be a nice Target guys okay
if we're able to go to the end once
again when whenever you use fibs uh
predictions to find Targets you need to
associate that with some natural
resistance levels a natural resistance
level is a level where you had a lot of
volume rejections support in the past
and here the best I have in this area is
25.5 okay
so
FIB gives you fibs give you
um some areas but the real resistances
or supports that you're going to use are
created by trend lines all right and
here we it's not very strong but it's
the best I have
so 25.5 so in this scenario maybe AMC
could go to 25.5 this would be the first
wave and then got rejected which would
be totally fine once again we're gonna
manage to that the second wave pullback
is very good it gives the opportunity
for buyers to get in the trades for
those who have missed it it gives the
opportunity to
um I mean it it just gives some air to
the move which is good otherwise like
I'm saying guys since a few days I'm
doing my live uh sessions is that if a
move up develops without any pullback
any corrections at some point everybody
is going to take profits bears are going
to attack and it's gonna be just a blood
path so we don't want that to happen so
we want to see this you know small
pullbacks correction consolidation
happening on low volume
okay so for now we're pushing higher
we're doing good Jimmy 150
that's serious
what a pain we miss that train
now it's not going to get back here now
you see if it gets back here brutally
it would even
we need to see what's going to happen
here for now the volume is low guys but
it's been only 12 minutes I don't want
to see a lower volume than that
and I don't want to see
a bearish Divergence but I'm afraid I'm
gonna see it I can already feel it
because look the volume starts quite low
so for now we are decreasing volume
is going to be bigger of course because
the candle is not finished and I don't
see how the macd can go higher than that
guys all right so I'm already feeling
that bearish Divergence is coming and
that we are going higher on lower volume
so yeah guys here we might see some
rejection happening if we reach this
levels and this could be the end of the
first wave so let's check out of that
okay and we are we can do a little bit
the same kind of countings guys here so
one two three four
s guys uh here the third wave is that
big that the fifth wave might actually
let's see guys today is a massive day
maybe we're just gonna go through the
160 level brutally today it's possible
as well uh
let's check the gamma because as you
know we have uh today is a big big
expiry day we had 4.2 percent of gamma
yesterday let's check today guys Jimmy
bam
stay with me I'm gonna do that
quickly guys I know that this
spreadsheet for some of you might be a
bit frightening but trust me it's very
important to keep an eye on all of that
okay so I'm retrieving
the information from the option Market
the date I get from Bloomberg guys with
my formulas using my spreadsheets
and this is very important to
you know money to the flows guys the
flows are what helps you to do the
market okay so why is it so low okay so
first here I have this
it's not good bam
okay let me try to understand what's
Happening Here
where is the gamma solo ah maybe it's
not pressing I know why because I'm not
seeing the gamma coming from the March
25th expiring
yeah it's pricing at zero all right so
how can I do that
um
[Music]
um
I need to change the dates
okay so make sure you see I'm going to
try that plus one let's see if it works
nice and looking okay whatever guys I
said I'm going to be quick here so I'm
not gonna fix my spreadsheet now uh the
okay I don't see the value of gamma but
I know it's big we can
um but I see everything else okay so
here we can see that uh bam let's move
that in the short squeeze
shortlist them
let's compare this value compared to
yesterday so the DTC is stable once
again because the volume is bigger I the
gamma is not good today because I cannot
compute the gamma of today it's just
um you know a formula issue because well
for whatever and what we can see is the
current synthetic shot that is growing
from four to five percent roughly uh
okay we can check the number of options
yesterday we had 17.5 million today we
have 20 million look that guys the 200
strike was at 2 million it's growing so
basically everybody's buying options
okay so I'm not gonna stay here longer
we can try to compute the uh
the the max paint is at 130 okay so not
the nice level
but uh let's see let's see guys um not
that many not that much information from
this uh today we what we know guys is
that the number of options on the 25th
of March expiry is absolutely massive
and you can see it here you can see that
the biggest strike is coming from the
200 strike which is on this 25th of
March uh maturity here as you can see
bam uh one uh one million shares sitting
at the 200 strike
I doubt we can go there but let's see
okay so uh let's continue to make some
assumptions some Jimmy guys what can
happen What could happen here
we can uh use fibs try to predict
uh try to predict what
levels could be reached for the top of
this first wave once again we can expect
a pullback to happen at some point
okay uh we can also wonder if this false
wave maybe it's it's the second wave and
we are in the third but I doubt it okay
let's first try to find the target for
the fifths
okay so you see 170 it's possible so
let's see I think 160 is a very strong
resistance level so I doubt we can
really go through it without a real you
know consolidation that we didn't have
for now guys as you can see uh so we can
very well just push higher and you know
squeeze hard you know that's possible
um but it's not the preferred scenario
here for now what is happening is that
we are grounding higher but without real
strengths since uh Wednesday so let's
see if today we're able to have a very
strong day if yes
um this would confirm that we developed
in five waves on the upside uh this
would confirm that this move is very
impulsive and this would make a second
wave pullback a very nice entry
opportunity okay guys so let's wait for
that let's see what uh what the market
can give us here
um
yesterday's volume traded was lower but
like I said this is rather good news to
see a low volume trading on the
consolidation
uh then
let's see guys my take for now is that
this is the first wave and that we're
gonna have a second wave pullback okay
and this is pretty much the scenario I
had for quite some time uh this of
course strong move that happened this
week was uh very you know surprised
everyone but uh what we can expect from
here is maybe something like this guys
you know this here A second wave and
then bam bam bam okay this would be once
again a very bullish scenario uh a first
wave that go that comes here okay
something like that then if you're a
second wave and then the third four five
okay so two early guys to talk about
Target I'm just giving you the type of
structure that we can expect to see
um it's also possible that we just go
higher higher higher okay but we know
what happens when this uh when we are in
this scenario okay if we just go higher
without breathing uh at some point we're
gonna see some strong reactions so we
prefer to you know take our time just go
or higher correct little bit you know
use fips to enter here same thing guys
we can use Fibonacci ratios to get those
pullbacks okay so usually second and
fourth waves they like to correct to the
38.2 if the movie is strong or 61.8
percent retracement if the correction is
deeper so we can already start to do
that a little bit
okay so we can check for example here
this third wave look how strong it was
guys the third wave didn't even crack to
the 38.2 so for this very reason we
definitely cannot assume this is a
second wave because there was there is
an alternative counting where you could
do something like that okay one two
three four five is complete okay and we
completed the second web and we are
doing a massive third wave I don't think
this is happening because uh a second
wave that is not even going to the 122
uh to the 38.2 percentage ratio of
Fibonacci is unlikely to be a second
wave so it's my guess is rather that
it's a very uh quick and shallow Force
wave that we're doing in fifth so let's
see what what this fifth wave can give
us for now as you guys can see nine
minutes left we still have lower volume
uh this is weak for now compared to what
we had before so if we are not able to
make something very strong today uh this
move would probably enter a small pool
batch correction that would be a very
nice entry opportunity that could last
maybe a couple of days maybe you know
early next week we're not there yet so
let's see what the market gives us today
first guys
and then of course
we're gonna analyze what's gonna happen
next week but let's see first what's up
what happens today
so we have some other place at 140 on
gme
we missed uh the we missed the reaction
this morning guys
on the 20 minutes time frame once again
the 20 and the 50 period moving averages
seem to be acting as support uh I now
will pay attention more to the 50
because the 20 has been broken and not
really acted as resistance on the way up
so this moving average on the 30 minutes
time frame the 20 period is not anymore
uh the one that Traders really pay
attention to so I don't want to pay too
much attention to it as well but here of
course we had to do two of them at the
same level so
once again it's a it's a pain we didn't
set up the trade quick enough but but
this is part of the game let's check
quickly what we have on the rest of the
market guys
and uh and then of course we're gonna
come back to AMC Jimmy so we're gonna
check Global Market quickly we're going
to check the vix guys uh that is giving
us very good information
okay I have seven minutes left I see the
volume growing so that's good and Jimmy
is ripping that's very good as well
let's stay here a little bit more guys
okay
starting to be positive that's great
okay guys so Global Market spy first so
here as you know guys we are uh neutral
plus so slightly bullish since we broke
out above the 445 446 level right this
was uh where we had the 200-day moving
average as well coming here
and uh we had a little uh fake Out Below
this level and boosted back control
quickly so here it's a bit the same
situation yes we didn't pull back for
quite some time uh since we since March
14th so it's been 10 days that we are
just moving strongly higher without uh
breathing you can see volume is
decreasing
uh the momentum is still going up so
that's good we don't have any bearish
Divergence so for now we don't have any
reason to believe uh spy will uh pull
back okay uh and especially we are not
close to the resistance that is at 457
460. so my take like I'm saying for a
couple of days is that we stay in this
range Grand higher on Lower volatility
lower volume than get a little rejection
uh so this scenario is valid this is
what is happening for now so
um
what else can we say here
yeah and what is going to be very
interesting guys if this happens like
that if we get this false wave pullback
uh so of course this would be a very
nice area to buy to set up a trade with
the stop loss here because we are not
sure at All That official is going to
come but if the fifth wave comes we are
in it and uh if it involves huge volume
and goes through the 460 level we're
gonna be out of trouble for quite some
time this would give Bulls the advantage
for the coming month all right here for
now we have uh let's say boost and
control for the coming weeks maximum
okay to get Bulls in control for the
coming month we need more we need a
strong volume going through the 460
level all right guys so this is what
we're looking for on the spy uh I could
go on a shorter time frame but let's be
honest we prefer to stay on AMC and gme
guys data doing great here
okay
so uh
what else can we do triple Q
triple Q
is pulling back a little bit
but
it's strong guys it's a little bit the
same analysis we have on the Spy
um because do we have a negative beta
today
you see whenever we are in a bull run
having a negative beta it's rather good
news to me because it reminds me the
good days guys the good days were where
we were in the strong bull market and
whenever the global market was pulling
back uh AMC and GP were ripping okay so
this is an environment that reminds me
good things so if I see this you know
um patterns or you know correlation
happening I would feel more confident in
uh what is happening on AMC and Jimmy
so triple Q like I said so here same
thing as for Spy Guys the support area
is at 350 okay it has not been tested
so let's check here if you have pulled
back anything no guess we are just
moving strongly higher since uh we were
trading at 320 roughly so uh so same
thing as we can expect
uh at some point a pullback here is it
gonna happen now let's check let's check
if we have some British bearish signs of
um of you know small correction pullback
uh here once again volume are going
lower
uh okay I'm gonna answer the question
about Max Payne very soon
so max plan for what AMC Jimmy and here
as you can see uh we didn't pull back at
all yes yes we're looking for some
bearish uh signs if any uh for now we
don't have because on The Daily time
frame the match is going higher the RSI
is going higher
okay how many calls in the money I'm
gonna check that guys I'm gonna take all
of that
okay on the first time frame
we have the macd that is flattening
okay
but we're still above the uh you know
this moving average that is acting well
as support for the past week so nothing
bearish as well and we have the vix
which is interesting guys to pay
attention to what is happening on the
vix look at that bam uh since I started
to make my live updates uh we were
having a fix at 23 and I told you guys
that the most likely scenario is that we
see a vix coming back to 20 with the
global market grounding higher for now
this is what is happening
I still believe this scenario is the
most likely one
um
so vix is going lower so it's good it
means that markets are
reassured uh confident you know the fear
is going uh a little bit I didn't see
news uh since yesterday the only news I
found I mean about the global markets uh
the only news I found is that some banks
like
um Merrill Lynch are giving positive
um suggestions I mean positive
information about the market they they
switch from neutral to bullish on equity
for the coming weeks you know things
like that so I'm not sure if they're
doing some technical analysis like me
it's it seems more like technical
analysis than uh macroeconomic analysis
because uh the news are not amazing guys
let's be honest
so
um only technical analysis can I think
tell you that we are bullish for the
coming weeks despite the bad
environments in which we are and then
we're gonna see what's gonna happen okay
I'm gonna check uh how many up how many
calls in the money that's a good
question because
um the number of calls that are in the
money
so let's check only on the 25th of March
expiry what's going to happen is that
market makers are short calls right
because retail are buying options so if
a written investor is in the money on a
long call option it means that an option
Market maker is short a call option that
is in the money so what's going to
happen on at the expiry is that there's
going to be a shared delivery so the
retail investor is going to receive a
long position so let's say 100 shares if
he has one option and the market maker
is going to receive is going to have a
short position of 100 shares so is there
a short selling restriction yesterday I
had this question
we don't have the short selling we have
it on gme we don't have it on EMC I mean
from what I'm seeing
um so
so let's see what's going to happen
but
but anyway option market makers are not
usually holding uh you know keeping a
short position and purpose all right
they usually cover right away hedge
funds it's different all right hedge
funds especially those who are
specialized in schroding the business
relies on you know shorting companies
and keeping the short positions but
option market makers uh of course some
of them are keeping some shots but they
prefer a thing to cover quickly they
don't have I think uh big limits about
that because it's not the Core Business
they're not supposed to keep short
positions for a long time so um what
would usually happen is that they're
gonna cover uh either by buying shares
today at the close
or Monday morning okay I'm not exactly
sure what makes the most sense if I was
holding a short option that I cannot
close
I would buy today I would buy today at
the close so that I'm flat so they would
probably buy today at the close or
anytime during the day so now that I
have that I have explained that for
those maybe who were not aware of the
mechanics of options let's check how
many options are the money so for AMC
and gme you're asking for AMC okay so
I'm here on gme so let's do gme first uh
bam so Jimmy let's say let's say we
close above 150
so we have
uh 14
000 so 1.4 million shares okay
uh below one hand one uh 150 1.4 million
shares and the share float is 60 million
so it's around two percent of the chef
float which is
not
impressive but it's substantial already
and it can make it can make a difference
during the day now let's check AMC and
of course if we go higher this is what
we could do gamma screws because if we
go higher it's not 1 million shares it's
5 million shares all right 4.6 let's
check AMC and I'm Gonna Give You Max
Payne as well I would like to buy some
options on AMC okay
we're gonna check that I think today is
a better day to buy options than on
Tuesday because the volatility is
cheaper
okay
all right so on AMC same thing 25th of
March how many options in the money so
let's say AMC is at 20 okay if we go
above 22 for example
we have
so some
seven million shows
okay 70 000 option
which is times 107 million shares data
in the money if we close above 22 so 7
million shares compared to the shop
float same thing is around 1.5 percent
um and in terms of volume Trading
seven million shares what was the volume
trading yesterday on EMC because it's
roughly the number of shares that market
makers would need to buy during the day
so it's interesting to compare it to the
total volume setting during the day
because you know it gives a good
information about is it going to be easy
for them to buy it without disturbing
the market or not yesterday we had 68
million shares guys so it's 10 percent
of the
total volume trading trading yesterday
so of course it has a substantial impact
so we can assume they're gonna buy
during the day
okay
but we can also assume that basically I
have two different ways to see it
because
um
for some options
I don't think they buy share they buy
shares against it which means they sell
the option and they just hope the option
will not finish in the money all right
and the cash in the premium but for the
shares the the strikes that are closer
to the money the 21 Stripes 22 strike
they usually buy shares against that
okay so we cannot assume they just have
this short position and hope for the
best you know they probably already have
both shares this is the gap I guess and
the higher we get the Motions they need
to buy so when I send 7 million shares
mean to be bought it's assuming they
didn't buy any yet but it's not the case
I believe I believe they bought at least
half of it at least and maybe even more
sometimes they even you know anticipate
a strong move on the upside by even uh
hedging over hedging and when they hedge
they need to buy shares so sometimes
option market makers they keep a long
position to protect the short call
positions all right so we don't know if
those shares have been bought already if
they need to bite soon we just know that
either they bought it
or they're gonna buy it and so they keep
this pressure and the higher we go the
more shares they need to buy so this is
the reasoning that can be made here it's
ripping again guys
we're getting close to the 160 level so
let's see if we see some um
okay so you see the volume first thing
okay that's pretty good guys okay I told
you that we need to check the volume and
see if the volume uh trading is bigger
than what we had before so it's smaller
than this one definitely but it's bigger
than the one we had yesterday so it's
starting well guys all right yesterday
was a low volume day today is not going
to be a lower volume day it's a part of
the volume chaining on the 23rd of March
the biggest volume since a very very
long time happening on a strong move up
yet so everybody both today uh in this
move up so it's pretty good
let's see what can happen let's see if
we can grab some shells guys at some
level okay and I had a question about
AMC options so
bam let me check that
AMC versus Jimmy which has higher
potential okay I can discuss that we can
also check what is
um the
uh if Jenny is still trading at the
premium today I remind you guys that I
took some levels where we had a lot of
volume and I considered that this prices
were equivalence prices that were fair
prices where did they put that share
okay so I remind you for example
120 on gme is equivalent to 21 on AMC
because we had a lot of volume that was
exchanged there in the recent month so
we can consider that whenever Jaime is
at 130 AMC should be at 21. so if I use
this ratios
okay bam
so right now Jimmy is
um trading at the 15 premium compared to
EMC so if you need to buy I mean not
Financial advice but just looking at
that information it's better today to
get some AMC shares that are cheaper
compared to gme okay which doesn't mean
that Jimmy cannot go higher of course
but it means that at some point there's
gonna probably be a catch-up of AMC so
and a ketchup of 15 all right guys so
this is the first thing
good morning from Chile Hey Brother
uh then some option strategies about AMC
guys so let's have a look at that right
now once again like I said the
volatility is lower today because
whenever we have that strong moves up
like we had here uh then market makers
are scared and they put the volatility
very high the higher the velocity the
more expensive value options and
whenever we have a post a correction the
pullback then the volatility is cheaper
so right now I think the volatility is
cheaper because we didn't move strongly
yesterday and for now we don't have a
plus 10 we have plus three so option
market makers that I think still kind of
relaxed uh for now
so let's have a look at what kind of
options so yesterday we were discussing
the April 25th strike
so first let's you know make some
scenarios because
if you guys I think that apple is good
so we're gonna discuss an option
strategy on Apple and an option strategy
on June okay if you do April let me so
guys
April is going to expand on the 14th of
April so it's here right so in this
situation uh you want your option to be
in the money if once again this is a
bullish case guys so in the good
scenario we are 25 of course we can
close that 30 but let's assume we're
going to close that 25 which is already
quite bullish you want your option to be
in the money so you want your strike to
be below 25. so uh you want to maximize
your profits at 25. so I think that
going to some April 22 stretch is
appropriate let's see how much this is
our costume guys
yeah so it costs two dollars roughly so
the volatility for now is 338 so I think
I'm live on the volatility so it's it's
not lower for now it's it's still
expensive guys so just be aware that you
pay quite a lot for this volatility the
fair price of that like I showed you
yesterday it should be 100 so your
options instead of being 2.3 dollars
should be 1.7 just keep that in mind
guys option market makers are charging a
premium for now on AMC
um on the apple maturity so that's why
it's better to buy shares sell options
all right this is only my view I'm an
option Trader and in this situation uh
you know it's better to have the same
position as option market makers who are
professionals who optimize their profits
and those guys like I said they sell
options to retail and they buy shares so
it's good to do the same as they do okay
but we are not option market makers so
um so we can still buy options if uh if
you guys really want that so I I think
that the 22 strike on apple maturity is
good once again because it's gonna give
let's check the real press of that
okay
okay
so
add Pro
the 22 strike is not here let's add it
okay
you see so like I said 2.3 uh is around
2.3 okay two dollars 30 cents and what
you can expect using this strategy if
AMC closes at 25 you invested 200 today
and you're gonna make uh so 100 times
the difference between 25 and 22. so
three
thousand dollars is it
no sorry it's three hundred dollars
three hundred dollars it's not
amazing profits this once again because
the volatility is extremely expensive so
guys
um I would not do that let's be honest
it's better to buy shares all right and
sell options once again I know you don't
want to sell cool options
um but
but this is the best strategy to have
for now as the first wave uh but as we
didn't have the second wave put back so
we can expect it to happen so it's
better to buy shares and to sell the
April 25 code for example all right and
cash in some premiums to do covered
calls is the best strategy to me today
as the velocity is very expensive and we
didn't pull back yet uh after the first
wave so I'm giving you an example you
have 100 shares the cat
and every 100 says you sell for example
some apple 25 so how much is it worth
today
okay so we saw that we is buying the 100
uh with the buying the 22 strike uh you
can make 300 of profits if we close at
25 okay and by doing that by buying 100
shares and selling one call uh you can
make at 25 1000 US dollars but so three
times more all right uh but of course
you have more risk because you start to
lose money uh
below so the option you're gonna set it
1.5 so you start to lose money below 19
and you you can have a big loss so it's
totally a different uh risk that you
take you can buy some puts even if you
want to capture risk but we said that
buying volatility is not making sense
today so
um let's go to other maturities
because I think that what you guys are
looking for is some options that can
really really give you nice profits if
we squeeze so let's do rather this
scenario so I don't think apple maturity
is the right maturity to find uh to buy
for this kind of scenario I think it's
better to go to the June maturity for
example
uh because we are kind of sure that
everything will be done and then
the best timing let's discuss about
timing first the best timing is during
the second wave pullback okay and I'm
gonna be here guys to buy options myself
uh during the second wave pullback for
now I don't think it's the best time
because the volatility is High
um and the time is playing against us as
you know whenever we buy options so the
best thing is to wait as long as
possible so that the options value is
decreasing okay and to do it whenever
everything is calm okay when you have
strong moves up once again we saw that
option market makers are charging a
premium of around uh 50 cents guys even
60 cents by option like they make you
option 30 persons more more expensive
than what it should be so this is just
you know a scam organized by option
market makers but once again they need
to provide liquidity so they have no
choice they need to show a bid and an
offer and every other for the show
investors are going to buy it so of
course they're just you know moving up
this
um this bid offer that they need to show
so it's totally I would say
understandable that the volatility they
use for pricing is higher than the
volatility they should use that it's
kind of expected that they charge a
premium because they need to do that to
protect themselves otherwise they're
exposed to a massive risk if things go
wild on the upside
so and once again they move the offer
price but they moved the bid price as
well so you can you can as well sell
this volatility like they do at a
premium so this is once again I think
the right trades to do in this kind of
environment uh but whatever we were
discussing what kind of options we can
buy to take advantage of a potential
squeeze okay
so patent show squeeze would look like
that guys okay
uh don't pay attention to my targets
once again it's too early we need to
have at least the first wave complete
and the second wave to start to discuss
about the third wave targets for now
we're not there yet
but we can already assume that just
looking at that the second wave
pullback could happen around April all
right around mid-april in two three
weeks okay so in two three weeks
I think this would be the right time to
buy options so you can buy some today if
you want not Financial advice but I'm
just saying that keep some cash maybe to
buy more options in mid-april because I
think that there's going to be a nice
opportunity mid-april
um so this is for the timing and once
again because the volatility is going to
be cheaper if we have this kind of
pullback like we had here okay maybe
it's going to be quicker I don't know
here the pullback lasts five days so we
are not we didn't complete the first
trip maybe it's going to happen next
week I don't know but let's see the
thing is that whenever it happens the
volatility is cheaper and Corruptions
are cheaper so uh then if it happens
what options are good to buy so like I
said guys it's not good to go to very
out of the money options because the
volatility used to price them is even
higher so I think that going to you know
a 30 strike on June
is good
okay the 30 strike I think is one of the
best strikes we can have
so it's still 140 strike so you see the
price now let's consider we buy it the
price so you see the volatility first is
more fair is only 125 on this uh strike
compared to 100
realize volatility so we can see there
is only 25 premium so let's imagine so
this costs 2.5 let's imagine the price
is fair
if they priced it fair it was it
wouldn't cost 2.5 it would cost 1.5 guys
so you see
you are losing basically uh 40 of your
Investments
just because option markers option
market makers are scared of what could
happen all right so
take take this into account as well uh
then maybe I'm a bit overestimating the
fair price but at least they charge you
50 cents more all right
uh but whatever is the price and it
still it can still make a lot of money
if things go right so let's imagine we
buy one share and once again I'm very
sure that if we have a second wave
pullback the volatility would be not 125
but maybe 105 110 so this option would
be much lower plus the time would be
passing so you can get this option I'm
very sure half of the price it's it is
now even before things get wild so uh
let's run into that right now this
option costs 2.6 dollars
okay let's check exactly the real press
because here I'm using some
um black shots from approximations so we
said 2D strike
okay so you see the price is 2.2 to 2.5
so I'm rather I'm having a good
um estimation of this
uh so this track is good to buy once
again but I would not buy too many today
uh because I think you can get it at
half the price so maybe using the strike
and averaging down okay so maybe getting
some at 2.3 adding more at two adding
more at 1.7 adding more at 1.4 you know
doing four Clips not Financial advice
each time you know a little bit more so
maybe one at 2.5 one add two
um
and then you make two at one point seven
and
three at one point four something like
this you know you you you take each time
a little bit more and so it's ten
options so it's a lot of money so I'm
sure uh maybe this is too much but it's
just an example this is what I would be
doing for example if I wanted to load
the stripe but once again I personally
won't be buying options today I think
the velocity is too high I would wait
okay
thank you brother thank you I appreciate
that you guys enjoy this information but
yeah I'm trying to give you the best
content possible and once again you know
I'm coming from this industry so
I know a little bit how things work
which doesn't mean that it's you know
easy to make money every day but
whenever you know some things
it just helps to you know avoid some
obvious traps that happen abuse scams
you know I lost my magazine
okay make these back so
uh let's see a little bit what is
happening so Jim is still doing great
you see
we had this
147 resistance this morning and as you
can see we went through it and we pulled
back right on it so we didn't set up a
trade here because whenever a resistance
is broken but you don't have a nice
consolidation before uh
it is not a strong support So 147 acted
as support a bit by luck but it was not
a strong support so we're still waiting
for more information if we want to set
up some trades let's see
all right then AMC what is it doing guys
let's check on the hourly time frame
okay same thing as we went through
uh the 20.6 level and detected as
we as support 20.62 has been hit and
then we had a bullish reaction
so once again for now I didn't buy
shares today we bought
um some shares on Tuesday at 18.7 uh for
now you know I'm waiting because
we could very well have a massive move
up today but we could very well have
just you know uh average move up and
then best starting to Take Back Control
so I'm more focused on this
um so this is a force I'm more focused
on the second wave pullback
so I want to see a nice the perfect
scenario would be to see a nice fifth
wave to the 25 25 area if we see that it
means that things are kind of respecting
Elliott wave theory respecting
um FIB ratios
so it's gonna make this move easier to
analyze for the future uh and it's gonna
make sure that not true but you know
more likely that the second wave
pullback uh is gonna be both because if
we have five waves that are very clear
on the upside
um I mean this is bullish right if we
have we don't know if it's three or five
let's say we don't make any High here I
can count five waves if I want sorry my
mouth is not not working okay here if I
want I can't find five waves all right
once again Elio 12 is subjective uh so
look I can very well do that
and say oh look I have five waves but
you're gonna tell me yeah but your fist
wave is very small all right so you see
the thing is that it would not be clear
if we do this fifth wave to the 25 area
no one can tell me that I don't have
five waves I mean it's very obvious that
I have five waves up and everybody sees
it best know it best would have lost
money between 22 and 25 so you know a
fifth wave on the up five waves
developing on the upside is not only
something that is you know followed by
guys that know about elio23 area 12
theory is based on what was happening
before you know Elliot arrived so uh
it's you know just interpreting what
um kind of emotions memories investors
have and I can tell you that the fifth
wave is a huge defeat for Bears okay
because you know they just try to push
the price action lower lower and if if
they here get defeated with high volume
then
there will be buyers as well on the
second wave you know what I mean so this
fifth wave is what is creating the
thought process of bells to be like all
right I don't want to find myself in
this situation anymore I will not keep a
short position I will buy it back okay
so this one this is why the fifth wave
is very
um useful for
um you know predicting a new move up to
start for now once again we only have
three waves up to me I don't I don't
count five waves here we have something
very impulsive already with huge volume
so it looks very much like a third wave
but for now we don't have the fifths we
don't have a new high above 22 and on
gme we did a new high
so we are in a situation that I was a
little bit fearing we are making a new
high
but
without momentum look at the macd very
low on the 20 minutes time frame I can
switch so for now this is you know this
is not bullish
uh this is rather suggesting that we're
gonna have maybe we're gonna ground
higher to the 160 level
but I doubt we just destroy it
if we don't see some momentum coming
okay so and of course if the momentum is
coming it's going to be too late so
basically I can only feel wait for the
price action to tell me what is more
likely to happen later for now I have no
clue we can very well have a massive
move up to the 160 170 area today we can
very well get rejected now right now we
have to me a little bit of bearish
um signals because as you can see we
made a new high
and whenever you make your new high
usually Bulls should be all right we're
doing it again and this is what we felt
you know we were saying Jimmy's reaping
but no one was buying all right so this
is the reason why and baz was selling uh
there were probably some profit taking
as well so for now this is what is
creating a bearish Divergence is when
bulls making you high but are not able
to take the momentum with them and on
higher volume all right so for now we
have a bearish Divergence that appeared
on the one hour one hour time frame
we have this bearish Divergence on the
20 minute time frame
let's check the forward time frame
we have we don't have the bearish
Divergence of the first time frame so
it means whenever you have some
divergences on shorter time frame only
it doesn't give you good information for
I would say the
I don't know you can roughly multiply
the time frame by 10 this is just a rule
of thumb that's the first time frame
gives you information for roughly the
week to come and so for the week to come
for now we don't have a bearish
Divergence but on the 30 minutes and one
one hour time frame we have it but every
move up often starts with the bearish
Divergence and then the bearish
Divergence disappears if Bulls are able
to really create some momentum so maybe
we're not gonna have it in 30 minutes or
one hour but for now we have it
and
um and this bearish Divergence might
usually you as the Buddhist momentum is
still strong I think the most likely
scenario even if this bearish Divergent
stays is that we ground a little bit
higher you know on low volume and
basically what I'm using here is the
fact that whenever something big happens
the movie had this morning is bigger it
always takes some time before you know
um before being forgotten and best
remember that and bears maybe are not
selling right now they'll thread a
little bit but in a couple of hours or
even you know a couple of 30 minute
scandals so still a couple of hours but
um they would feel like Bulls are not
that strong anymore so if we stay here
in this area for the coming two hours
just like you know hovering around 150
to 153 uh
this could be the end of the first wave
so I wish we could go higher because for
now this fifth wave is very weak
it's still a fifth wave but it's not
really giving us higher levels so let's
check what kind of FIB ratios we have
for that
huh
you see it's very weak 38.2 percent for
fifth wave it's not it's still a fifth
wave but if we have this kind of fifth
wave
um
I don't know
it means that the second wave would just
pull back lower it's so bullish even if
we if we're not able to make new highs
today it's too bullish but it would
signal probably that next week is going
to be at least at the beginning of the
week a little bit more calm with some
consolidation on low volume nothing bad
just like we had during this first wave
maybe something a little bit longer
maybe like an ABC you know this ABC was
not very clear the second wave ABC would
maybe looks a little bit like that okay
we can already make some scenarios guys
we can assume this fifth wave won't go
much higher you know I'm just you know
building some scenarios and then we're
gonna see let's say we go to 160 today
uh then usually second waves pull back
go to the 38.2 or 61.8 so 61.8 for
second wave
uh I mean it's it's a little bit deep so
let's say to the 8.2 which is the 120
level so I think that this scenario is
very likely to happen
okay that we see again 130 level next
week
and that this would be a very nice
opportunity to buy especially that now
you remember yesterday uh I was telling
you yeah but the 100 into the level is
not an obvious uh support because we
didn't have any short-term clean
reactions around it right now we had it
okay we had it and it's not 130.7 so
let's adjust it as you guys know uh for
those who are following my videos for
some time
whenever you have a support level
a trend line supported resistance that
you got using previous highs like for
example those I had here and the price
action is giving you new new information
on the shorter term you need to trust
the shorter term information so here we
adjust the trend line okay and Bama so I
match one two three short reactions I
don't match anymore this but I don't
care okay
and so right now the new support is 127.
uh then gme going higher so you still
have a nice fight here let's see what we
would need to see once again
ideally something that you know is going
to 170 this would be really perfect it
would meet uh the FIB ratio uh
it would be the best case scenario
so let's see if we're able to do that
today it's a bit far but you know we're
already up eight percent on the day
massive option expiry everybody knows
that
so everybody is bullish
okay so vix still dropping guys
coming soon close to the support levels
let's see let's see what can happen here
Euler
oil is yesterday we saw that guys we
keep an eye on the oil price because as
you know guys it's very related to the
FED policy regarding inflation because
oil prices is like the raw material of
raw materials right you need oil to
produce anything
so if oil price is more expensive other
raw materials are going to be more
expensive like Metals uh that need oil
to be produced and it's gonna
ultimately impacts the whole you know uh
chain of goods and it's gonna of course
create inflation so and you guys know
that the FED is trying to tackle
inflation right now for the past six
months even for the past year but
especially since the war has started and
so uh if we see
the oil price going higher it makes them
in a more difficult situation so an oil
price that is stabilizing below 115 is
rather good for the markets okay we
don't want to see crazy moves Happening
Here on the upside I'm afraid they could
happen though just technically uh so
that's why I'm still very
cautious about the global market I'm
still having a short position on Triple
q that I'm going to increase around 370
okay but I'm of course I'm having long
positions on many stocks with just some
protection look Jimmy Papa
coming back again
here to the 156 level guys we're making
new highs so let's see if booze managed
to take the macd with them take the RSI
okay we have a mixed day
here is my Discord and you know I keep
an eye on a few stocks here that detract
interests and I like to just have a
quick glance at that and if I see it's
all green I know Meme stocks are doing
good and here I see some green and some
red so some of them are dumped some of
them
are pushing higher
crypto is bullish
okay oh and down so today is a mixed day
as you can see NASDAQ it will be down s
p a little bit up gas up oil down crypto
app
meme stocks are mixed I mean gme and MC
are of course
pushing higher but you know to me it's
yes on Tuesday it was not like that
remember guys everything was green uh so
we we can already see that
you know it's not exactly as strong as
it was before so this the Bulls are
still in control but you know not as
much as they used to be at the beginning
of the week so it's not bearish of
course but it's just one information
that you can keep in mind
okay so here as you can see for now we
are in this scenario hovering around 155
level
okay
and hit that like button exactly guys
come on give me some love
all right so vix
dropping like a stone guys of course
because the global market is not moving
so
so of course the volatility is dropping
this is good for the market
okay what else can we look at let's have
a look at Bitcoin guys
okay I'm gonna check out your stocks
very soon guys so now okay I keep it in
mind
Bam Bam
I did nine yesterday
maybe you were not here anymore brother
I will do it again
okay let's have a look at Bitcoin fix
guys
we don't need to go through all the
cryptocurrencies but I told you we have
some breakouts happening on you know
some alt coins
um
and I'm keeping an eye on bitcoin
because this is going to give us the
direction of the rest of the crypto
market and you guys know what we're
looking for I can say it again but we're
looking for breakout with volume so just
like here a little bit okay remember
that it was in July 21 I was in current
team guys in my hotel in Hong Kong and I
remember I was covering Bitcoin at that
time and I posted many videos saying
guys it's coming back it's starting
again because we had break we had a
breakout with low volume at the
beginning and then the volume arrived
when we made a new high okay around 40
it was 40 000 at that time we got first
rejected so we are a little bit in the
same situation Luke
Bitcoin by the way is it didn't it
happen together with AMC no AMC happened
before but whatever
you know
we are we we have like many good
information coming from the crypto
market so
um like I said we have this download
scorpion trend line that got broken
yesterday guys we tried to buy some
Beetle shares here but I didn't have
permissions and anyway we didn't see the
pullback yet but whenever you have a
breakout without volume guys expect a
pullback a pullback will very likely
happen Okay and we're gonna be there to
buy it if we see some volume
so
the first High recent high is here okay
so this is the immediate resistance 45
780 okay guys so we can expect Bitcoin
to go there
and
get rejected just like it did here guys
remember the past is giving us precious
information we need to use it and here
guys it looks like a move that is just
one way up but it actually when you look
at it closer you can see that during
this move we went up up up up up and
then here look at this tail of the
26th of July 221 we went higher
and here the volume arrived okay
we went through this level got rejected
got back here the next day guys so here
you know it looks small but those are
serious moves guys we are talking about
uh 12 move up that got rejected so this
was the signal that things are hot so
now we're not having that because we
don't have any 12 move up and we don't
have any volume and from here at that we
can make a 12 move up if we do we would
go to 50 000 so maybe this is what's
gonna happen I don't know this would be
a good signal okay
so if we only go to 46 000 it would be
weak
I can still buy the retest but there is
a risk now if we go to 50 000 with a
strong move up then get rejected come
back to 45.46 this would be a level to
buy uh but for now we're not having that
once again we don't have volume so guys
technical analysis is very precious but
if you don't have the volume it means
that it didn't involve many investors it
means that most of investors didn't say
what they think about this market so it
just makes your signals not relevant the
same
so
um so yeah that's pretty much it
I can see the lights going higher come
on guys
hit that like button if you haven't done
it yet it's good for the channel
so what else do we have guys so yeah um
so my um Bitcoin is that we keep running
higher we have the first resistance at
45
700 roughly then maybe a pullback I
don't know I want to see if we have
volume for now it is unclear to me it's
looking good but I don't have any strong
view for now my view is that maybe
something is going to happen if the
volume comes for now the volume is not
here vix below 21 guys we're getting
close to the levels where we might
expect volatility to kick back again
um so we need to be prepared for that
you see I don't like to see that guys
this is what we call grounding higher
Jimmy's right now granting higher okay
so usually this precedes a small tool
back okay I'm just saying so let's see
if we have that
when would you buy more shares in AMC so
like I said for now I don't have any I
mean
I think that's right now the risk to buy
now as we saw
Jim is giving first signs of you know
potential reversal we did one two three
four five
uh so here what we can play is the fifth
wave on AMC but it can also be weak and
let's be honest nobody will take profits
at 22 or 23. so if you buy here right
now you can find yourself in a situation
if you buy shares it's fine because I
don't think we can go really below 20 if
we make this move then the level to buy
would be
uh
18 20. so this is the area to buy for
now I mean it's not clear enough
um depending on how high the first wave
goes the second wave pullback would be a
good buying opportunity but to know
where the second wave pullback could go
we need to know how high the first wave
goes if we have a first wave that is
maybe complete then the second wave
pullback could be lower than that so
today we don't know
okay the second wave pull back if this
first wave is complete I don't know I'm
just taking one scenario we could very
well see a second wave pullback that is
coming back to 61.8 percent uh
retracement of Fibonacci so it would be
16.5 it would be the breakout level so
this is possible as well so buying at 20
right now in terms of risk reward I mean
for little why not but
uh I would not build a massive position
here if we get back to 16.5 of course it
would be a very nice opportunity but I
doubt this happens uh so for now I'm
waiting to know to see you know and I
need to find to have more information
you know we have here now the 20.6 level
that is acting as support but once again
buying here if you use a stop loss just
below at 20 it makes sense uh so we
could do that but once again guys I
don't really like to use stop losses on
EMC and Jimmy
um it's not the kind of stocks where you
want to be doing that and it's not like
you know
um
it's not a thing but you guys want to
see so I prefer to just load more shares
when I see good levels and so here once
again it's a bit risky to load more here
because we can very well go over next
week it's possible guys even if on like
unlikely and uh
and here I think that you know even if
we go to if we go to 25 then it would be
much much easier to to find some um
some targets for entry on the second
wave
so
stop spamming what do you mean Brandon
Sisk
who is that what are you talking about
man
Intel what is this okay we can have a
look at Intel
okay so nine
children okay I had children we had
indeed some nice moves happening guys so
we let's have a look at that okay Nile
was asked first
so did I go through all the global
market information yeah so we did
Bitcoin we did spy we did the mcgme of
course we're gonna do that again guys uh
so till then let's have a look we had
some strong move happening yesterday is
pretty much in a nice situation
um because we have this downtrend and we
have a consolidation that is here
happening uh that happened on low volume
okay so this consideration is not
perfect because it is still going lower
we prefer to have a consideration that
is you know moving sideways then
dropping but it's still giving us nice
reactions and it's still enough to see
the Bollinger Bands tighter so uh
whenever we have that
and we have a breakout that is closing
above the Bollinger band this is usually
attracting a lot of Traders if this
breakout happens on volume and this is
what happens here so today we have a
continuation of this move
um
for now Bears a little bit in control
here the thing is that maybe
uh I mean you can see that it's the
first time we're really trying to Take
Back Control usually after such strong
moves down uh it takes a little back it
takes it takes a little uh time to
okay okay I got you Brandon
cool so who is okay
so up starts right so this is the the
spamming I guess but whatever
okay cool so
um chillray once again
uh I think that for now it's a bit early
to really
um
you know turn bluish on the long term we
have the 20 200-day moving average uh
here that is coming at 10.6 so this
might act as resistance if we get back
to it so for now once again
there is still three nice pumps to make
um I think that's set buying here is of
course too late uh that's why training
is not easy guys because you know to be
at the right time on the uh to be at the
right level on the right time is not
that easy here I think that we have some
nice consideration that can be used
you know around the six levels if we see
the price action coming back to six
uh this could be a nice uh entry level
until Ray once again I think that taking
profits early is appropriate in this
stock because it's the first time that
we see really Bulls trying to take back
control and once again after long uh
long down downtrends like that uh bears
are not letting letting it go right away
so we can expect maybe
um you know more sideways move before
really moving higher so let's see uh but
once again if AMC and gme start to
really you know squeeze it will of
course attract other stocks like tilray
sanjel you know
okay
X as well guys moving higher I'm
following the stock for quite some time
because it has a huge uh short interest
and it we had a massive breakout guys so
I'm showing you that but it's
unfortunately a bit late to get in for
those who are not in yet uh but this is
the kind of situation just I'm showing
you that so that you keep that in mind
you know you have a long downtrend with
a nice consolidation here what I call a
nice build up and then you have a
breakout with some volume okay so this
is what happened here and whenever you
have that usually you have a nice
continuation on the upside and share uh
there is I think 25 of short interest on
X which is a steel company so you know
producing still so raw materials
commodity so this sector is of course
booming
um
so yeah I think we go to 45 47 here I'm
not taking profits yet I'm in this trade
okay so I can have a look at Nile
okay
okay so check that yesterday already
okay
okay so as you can see we have here this
trend line
okay
it's the best I can do for now
it's not perfect because we don't have
that many reactions in the very recent
past but here we have one rejection
consolidating just below coming back and
testing it
uh the setup is not perfect because here
we have a resistance clearly that is
created at the 105 level roughly okay
maybe one level Okay so
uh it's not easy to trade this because
then we have another resistance coming a
little bit higher but the volume is nice
once again we have I don't like to see
this big red buzz on the way up okay it
means that Bears won the day uh won the
battle in that day uh and it was on a
huge volume so some balls and a lot of
bulls actually last money here that
because they both and it ended up uh
lower uh
so I mean it's looking like something is
up but this could very well be a pump
and dump okay for now we don't have
anything sustainable we don't have any
very good signals we have uh resistances
just above
um
so let's see what can happen here
let's see what can happen for now you
know you cannot make any Elliot with
counting here of course I would say that
if we close above 100 above one or five
uh
most likely the bullish momentum would
continue I'm coming nice coming back in
two minutes guys
foreign
what else do we have
uh okay
please look at Intel okay I'm gonna have
a look at that
so Knight is done
and what is upstart oops start is not
can you check nine I can't
okay so UD is actually ah and uji bro
from the Discord
of course I'm gonna answer your question
um I have some 12
dollars absolute puts from last week as
protection when is it the best time to
sell them ah I think right now is the
best time to sell them
because
your put options right now have uh some
value because of the volatility
and if we see a pullback happening even
next week uh I think that's
they are likely to
um you know the volatility which the
volatility will drop and the time makes
them cheaper so I think that
it's better to dump them as quickly as
possible
those 12s of Apple because even if we
have a pullback okay the only case it
would be worse more is if you have a
pullback early next week to the 16 area
uh
but even then the volatility would
decrease because the Privacy is Inc the
volatility is increasing on the upside
so if we have a pullback coming early
next week the volatility will probably
decrease and they would lose value
because of time and volatility but they
make they would be more expensive
because we are closer to 12 level but
most likely they would not be very much
more expensive and if we just move
sideways they will just convert towards
zero quickly right now how much do they
worth so April you said 12s
put yeah they're not worth a lot
there are 10 cents I don't think you can
get a much much better price
um
you can I would dump half right now and
you know keep the other half just in
case we have a brutal move down early
next week which I doubt would happen
okay I'm gonna have a look at
Intel
if people save Jimmy remained above 150
there will be options that buying 3
million shelves
Okay so we've okay so I can check that
quickly and then we check Intel but like
I explained on gme so let's check how
many options
but first the thing is that you cannot
consider that option market makers
didn't buy any shares yet okay they will
not keep a shot
full full shot position and then short
code positions they will they have
probably already hedged some of the
position by buying shares but let's
assume so three million shares yeah but
definitely that's the size I see but
first it's not 3 million
okay it's
1.5 million to go to 3 million
you need to go to the 200 strike okay so
first I disagree with the three million
value
uh
once again if we go to the okay let's
say 160
you are at 1.7 million shares and once
again
of course they're going to need to buy
this 1.7 million shares but in this case
they would only also need to sell the
shares that have bought against that
position that is expiring or uh that
they bought already before so we don't
know how many shares they bought already
but in the best case scenario they
didn't buy any
and they're gonna need to buy indeed 1.7
million shares now we can assume that
it's rather going to be half of that
because they probably have hedged at
least half of this so I would say maybe
around 1 million shares to be both uh
today and it's maybe not that the expiry
is during the day so right now for
example GM is pushing higher maybe
because uh some option market makers are
actually you know buying all right
so let's see for now we're soon you know
she Ah that's interesting
because we have a higher volume traded
the next hour
of training today
so that's
that's good
that's good guys that's good to see
that's good news
um
make this still lower but I doubt we can
really make have a higher macd but this
is rather telling me that there is
definitely a buying pressure today we
already had you know almost more shares
extends today than what we had on
Wednesday when we did plus 30 percent uh
yeah 23rd of March yeah Wednesday
so it's looking good it's looking good
definitely
okay you see we're moving higher
and the volume is increasing
check
AMC as well doing good
okay so what else you guys want to see I
can have a look at the ones you asking
me often so we had you know Mulan and
bbag those two get dumped uh yesterday
we saw that so I told you that we had
some support at 280
I was hesitating to take a position here
and I said that I won't be taking this
position because of the short-term
bearish signals I was seeing okay
remember we were seeing lower volume uh
lower momentum okay uh so this was
already some early bearish Sands that we
had so this is the reason why we didn't
take any position here and now we are
here you know correcting a little bit
pulling back nothing too bad but this I
mean
this doesn't look so strong to me
because the consideration is not clear
enough we don't know exactly where the
Bulls were the best Boozer to me around
150 so it's you know maybe we can find
something a bit higher so 1 90 maybe
okay
uh on Mulan
so and we still weaker volume just the
interest is going from Mulan to gme AMC
guys this is what is happening today
this is what happened the past few days
so
yeah that's pretty much it
okay so I'm gonna answer your question I
saw that
let's quickly look at bbag
and bbag like I said guys pretty boring
what is happening here because uh
you know we had this breakout that is
not very clear and we are considerating
just above so it's rather good that we
consolidate uh high once again in a move
it shows that Bulls keep uh pressure but
if the volume is not coming back this
pressure is eventually
um you know Fades and best Take Back
Control we are here I don't I remind you
guys were here in a downtrend okay so
Bears if nothing happens it's playing
for the best okay whenever you're in a
bull Trend if you move sideways it's
bullish because it means bears are not
able to you know push back the price
action lower the same thing can be said
whenever we are in a downtrend and we
start to move sideways it's not good
okay in the downtrend we need to move up
on high volume all right to show the
best uh what is happening uh so what
signs are you looking for to confirm the
wave has been completed on Jimmy and IMC
and that will see a pullback so I uh
discussed that a little bit at the
beginning of the video but I'm very
happy to discuss this again because it
is indeed very interesting thing so we
have three different things we can pay
attention to First
to know uh even four so the basic things
is that you can use some Elio 12
counting but once again on the hourly
time frame it's not giving very good
reactions uh very good I mean
um
information I mean it's good information
but it's not easy to make them to make
those waves really uh clearly and
sometimes you have some countings that
are not respecting the theory very well
but it's still one information that you
can use and if you see that you have
five waves that respect fibrations so
once again the feed rations you guys
know are you know the golden number
ratio so you measure for example the
third wave one plus three sorry and you
apply it to the bottom of the force so
here for example if we go to 170 I would
very likely think that this fifth wave
might be complete
um so you can use Elio 12 associate with
vibrations to find some targets then you
can check if you are coming close to
some resistances level that can also
signal that uh you know this is a Bear
Camp that so that it can give you some
information about
um about the fact that the rejection is
more likely to happen because you know
that bears are located there so this is
another thing but this is more static
information I would say
um and to really read the price action
you need to go to the dynamic
information so the dynamic information
is the information about the indicators
that are moving with time all right so
we have a few indicators we can use we
can use the volume we can use the
volatility and we can use the momentum
so
um the momentum can be read with macd or
RSI for example and we are then looking
for some kind of divergences so if we
see the price action making new highs
once again with a decreasing momentum
this is I mean decreasing momentum and
decreasing volume this is showing
weakness in the move up here we have
mixed signal because we have momentum
that is decreasing which is fair enough
because the momentum was extremely
strong here so you know having a
momentum that is high but less high is
not that bearish but it's still creating
a bearish dividend now if you have a
bearish Divergence with increasing
volume which we see right now
then you don't know you don't know
because you have mixed signals so if you
have a bearish Divergence we is
decreasing volume then you know that
Bulls are weak here they don't look weak
okay they just they're just not as
strong as they used to be on Wednesday
but come on Wednesday we did 30 up so
it's hard to be that strong every day
right uh so it's not so we have so so
again this is another method you can
look at so volume volatility uh and
um momentum then you can add
the Bollinger Bands without giving
information about
um
the volatility and whenever they are
tight it means that a reversal is likely
to happen okay it's of course not enough
but whenever they are wide and you have
high volume trading you can assume that
even if you pull that happens it's going
to be both whenever they get tight
then you can assume that
maybe reversal is underway so for now
for now as you can see so depending on
which time frame you're looking this is
another uh thing that is important is to
select properly the time frame and it
would take me too long to extend
everything here if you're interested
guys of course you know there is my
course on my website so do not hesitate
guys to
um subscribe to that you're gonna learn
an incredible amount of information you
know I put everything I know in there uh
but during my videos I cannot explain
everything as good as I did in the
course which is really you know step by
step so that you know everybody
understands what is the whole point of
this kind of analysis but here so yeah
uh so yeah I think I answered the
question
um I hope it was clear enough
thank you brother
so BBB why we can check that keeping an
eye on of course an AMC and Jimmy that
are moving high today
Jimmy's about to make a new High guys
bam it did
so we are coming coming guys to the
major resistance area
160 so let's see what's gonna happen
here we can very well go through it
brutally guys because if both are strong
and they manage to you know just
go through all the selling orders
then we would arrive in
an area where Panic under uh bare side
will start they're gonna start to panic
they're gonna start to be like okay we
need to take the loss and buy now okay
so this is the kind of things that can
happen if we go through the 160 levels
so let's monitor that I'm keeping an eye
on this of course
165 on Jimmy yeah that makes sense
because this is the 200-day moving
average I totally agree we can see we
have a Confluence of resistances that is
coming here we have the 160 level that
is uh I mean the natural resistance
created by the last consolidation we
have the 200-day moving average at 165
and we have this trend line that is not
very precise okay but this trend line is
you know just connecting the highs I'm
not matching perfectly I can do it with
the lock scale I can do it with the
regular scale it's not giving me very
precise signal but we have this
trendline coming somewhere here okay uh
by the way direction we're gonna have
today here if there is a rejection is
going to help us to place this trend
line well so that we can use it for
later if we're not able to go through it
at the first time so let's uh let's see
that as well
okay I'm gonna have a look at bbby
right now
okay and if you enjoy this content guys
push the like button hit the like button
okay BB why
okay BBY so like I said um I discussed
that yesterday I mean
I know that you know I have many
questions about that I know that you
know we had some bullish action press
action happening here but once again we
got sold off massively here so look at
that I mean this is no this is not a
clean shot we have those big volume
trading sometimes on the red day
sometimes on the Green Day uh and it
happens once and then it vanishes Okay
so
so we know that we can have this
interest coming but we we know that it's
hard to have a sustainable rally on this
stock I mean at least for now maybe
things are going to change but for now
this is what this is the situation uh
the situation is that sometimes we move
higher sometimes we move lower there
isn't nothing really clear to me the
price action is a bit disorganized let
me go on a weekly time frame maybe I'm
going to see cleaner on a weekly time
frame I prefer the child it's cleaner I
see better the reactions and I would say
that right now there is nothing easy to
make on this stock
um
you know even on the weekly time frame I
can see the big day the big volume is
happening on the red day
uh I checked nine already I can check it
again if you wish but I've done that
already before you can have a look
okay it's interesting guys we have this
negative beta at play right now Pam
NASDAQ using 70 bips
spyish but maybe soon negative and gme
AMC ripping so this is what we'd like to
see guys because this reminds us once
again what happened a long time ago guys
when we had this strong moves up
this you know squeeze situation okay
here we go SNP negative
all right NASDAQ keeping dropping okay
and gme plus 10 AMC plus five percent
all right this is looking quite good to
me guys
all right so let me finish on bbui
uh okay so once again I can give you a
view here but let's be honest my view
would wouldn't be strong
okay we can try to make some Elliott
wave counting here
okay on the very long term so one two
once again the third wave is the
strongest one so one three four five
okay
then here we have some kind of
Correction and I'm not sure this
correction is complete
so a b c probably something like that
okay so if this is the case once again
this is an assumption guys I don't have
enough signals here to
to really be sure of that but this is
possible once again during those
Corrections we like to see lower volume
I don't like to see this big volume
happening here especially in the red
there
uh bam so what levels would we need to
take back okay I will tell you so this
could be the bullish case okay so I'm
not saying this is happening of course
guys I'm just giving you
uh one scenario and
once again we would need to wait for a
clear first wave that could maybe go to
the 30 level and then you know some
consolidation either some consideration
before breakout here once again the
consideration is what is helping you to
know where are located the Bulls were
allocated to bears and this is what is
very helpful to
um
to know whenever a breakout is going to
be followed by a strong move so we're
looking for those considerations here we
don't have any you know the price action
just moving up moving down big volume
big volatility but nothing organized but
let's say we have that here we could uh
make a a play
um and then if we just go right through
this level go to the footy area and then
pull back to the 28 level this also
would be a nice opportunity to buy so
right now there's nothing to do we can
only monitor that but I would personally
not put my money in this for now
okay
what happens to NASDAQ so you understand
me already yes bro I did you can check
at the beginning of the live each time I
start with Jimmy and AMC and then of
course I get back to it many times uh
but yeah I'm Gonna Keep analyzing
AMC and Jimmy for sure
I like what is happening guys I like to
see this negative better at play
I don't know what is NASDAQ doing guys
but low volume just considering it's not
a big move yesterday we moved up two
percent yes so this is just a small
you know correction consideration
so let's see let's see what's gonna
happen Bam Bam Bam
what else we have guys Vicks starting to
move up so we went to 20.9 we didn't
even touch the 2011 I think we're gonna
go over I think things are not at all
starting to go to to look crazy
okay uh so what was I saying Nile please
okay
oh right bro but I did it I did it I can
do it again uh Nile to me
first thing look at that you see red do
you see more green or more red you see
red red right so I mean it's just the
first impression it's not enough to
really build the view but I mean bears
are winning every day all right that is
what is happening it doesn't mean we
don't move higher it just it just means
that during the day
um bears are stronger that's you know
investors are
buying less than they sell okay so this
is not you know showing any strong
bullish momentum all right by the way
the RSI is still below 50 okay simple
rule RSI above 50 is bullish RSI below
50 is uh bearish all right and here you
can see we are contained below 50 since
October 21 so if you see so we need to
combine a different indicator I'm not
sure exactly what is your question about
night but I can tell you when I would
personally uh be you know start to turn
bullish on this stuff first one out when
things will look green and not red
second so I mean investors are winning
days all right you don't need to make
plus ten percent even a plus two percent
but we close higher than we open is a
bull Victory so we need to see that so
that you know Bulls and the right man
said don't forget guys that
um those who make the market the volume
exchanged is not the volume traded by
investors who hold their shares all
right most of the volume traded is by
investors that buy and sell and if
they're making more money by selling
during the day than buying this is what
they would do all right so if you want
them to you know hand the price action
to go higher by you know and even the
algorithm everything you need to you
know you need to have victories of bulls
so that this is uh the
the mode that is making the more money
for those guys and this is what they're
gonna do they're gonna buy if it makes
more money for them they're going to
sell if it makes money for them so you
know this is what uh you need to pay
attention to when you arrive on a market
is it bullish or is it bearish right and
here it's bearish okay this is all I can
say now we can try to see where uh we
have some resistance areas and once
again we use trend lines logarithmic
scale regular scale and we try to see
what is fitting the best and here uh
on a logarithmic scale I have some
reactions here and we can see that the
trend line that is right now around open
9 is creating the resistance line so
first we need to close above that level
uh ideally an increasing volume but we
already have increasing volume on the
red day so that's why even if now we
have that the signal wouldn't be good to
use so I would personally not get in uh
so on my side to read it in bullish I
would say to I would need to see first a
few green there is not only one okay a
few green days so it's going to take
some time and a stabilization Above This
level above above the one or five area
so that the RSI would probably finally
get back above 50 and hold there all
right and once we have that for a couple
of days or maybe weeks then we need to
find some consolidation and use it to
enter all right this is what I would
personally do on the stock and then if
you just you know rips without me find
the other opportunities I don't care
okay
oh right so what else we have we can
check okay so CEI okay Scott let's take
CEI
so CEI
yeah so CI is like related to the energy
sector we add some nice moves happening
here before
uh I think we have a lot of short
interest in there so let's check quickly
that
okay so CEI I'm retrieving the option
Market I'm interviewing the short
position
and I'm trying to you know first
understand who is doing what on the
stock
okay
all right so
like I said we have some shot
12 percent of regular shot
uh two percent of synthetic short
and a lot of volume so the DTC is low so
okay we have some shots but there are
not under pressure at all so this
information is not that relevant uh do
we have gamma
uh gamma is you know zero point zero
percent compared to the volume traded so
same there's not going to be gamma
squeeze there's not going to be a short
squeeze here at least not for now now we
can have natural buyers that just you
know uh make the price action going much
higher this is very possible this is by
the way the usual way a suck is moving
higher right it's usually by buying by
it's usually buy us buying shares that
creates strong moves up rather than
Schultz covering right because whenever
you have shots
usually you know it means that we drop
all right so let's try to understand in
terms of technicals uh what could create
some bullish sentiment back in the stack
because clearly we are bearish okay I'm
here in a daily time frame
okay let's let's first do the weekly
time frame because this move down is
very long
okay so on a weekly time frame I'm
trying to find you know the trends and
trying to find what trendline is giving
me the best reaction it's not easy maybe
we have broken out above maybe not
because once again we don't have any
clear considerations it's hard to really
know if on the weekly time frame we are
above this trend line but what we know
is that the on the weekly time frame the
RSI is has never traded above 50 okay it
happened once and it got very quickly
rejected so bulls have never been in
control in the long term first
information so if we
um manage to have a positive an RSI
above 50 it would be the first thing the
first information that things start to
go better but seriously I doubt this
happens
um
because bears are very strong here so
what we are looking for is maybe more a
pump and then a dump okay
so for to analyze that we're going to
Shorter terminal we're going to Shorter
term and we try to do the same thing
okay so first we can look at Mac grsi so
here we get definitely there is a battle
for the past here I recite sometimes
about 50 then holding a couple of weeks
month then below 50 then again you know
so just ups and downs okay now let's try
to find some information about where are
the resistance levels and what levels
can tell us that you know bears are you
know retreating or things like that so
we have this trend line but let me get
rid of it I don't like it it's not
precise it's polluting the analysis I'm
doing on the daily time frame so I don't
need to see it here we have a clear
Trend that got broken in Feb all right
got broken after low volume what we're
looking for is some reversal signs
reversal science arrived first whenever
you have balance between booze and best
and then you need to have some signal
that is sent that a camp is taking the
lead here and this balance occurs
usually on low volume so this is a nice
environment for a reversal to happen
then we have here a first information
big volume okay big volume but then
strong red day so not very clear and
then starting again okay so here we have
some a lot of volatility a lot of
instability what we can say is like
despite this strong uh red day we had
you know bulls that were gathered looks
like they were around this trend line
and Bam they push the price action
higher alright so what can we expect
from here
once again we can see you know things
are not clear because big day Big Green
Day big victory the next day the volume
is even bigger so this is a pump and
dump okay so we are in this situation
where it pumps it dumps okay so can
another pump arrive because this is I
think the question you're having
um so of course it can
uh it's as you can see very hard to buy
it on the way up because things are
moving very quickly and then they dump
very quickly as well so I think that the
stock is good to buy on the way down
okay whenever the volume is low like now
but you need to be prepared that
it just you know grants lower because
once again we are an environment where
we move quickly higher and then slowly
lower quickly higher so we can very well
move slowly lower so here if you believe
in the step which is once again about
energy you know camber energy let's
check exactly what they do but I think
the best strategy is just to average
down
in this situation we can have a look at
options
um okay
Cameron is your princess and Energy
Company the company explodes develops
and produces crude oil in natural gas
all right so that's pretty good
okay I don't understand why they would
they must have
um not a very good management
I mean the company is probably not
doing so well because the price is below
one so I'm always you know a bit uh
careful with any stock that actually
below you know two three
uh
it's hard to get back from there
this is what I I I'm seeing whenever you
enter this area it's like you know best
will usually not let it go above so
um resistance R4 so first once again
here the type of strategy that can be
used is just to buy on the way down so
let's try to find some support levels so
once again a support can be created by
uh any uh trend line I did TL r a
children you can check in the past bro
if you don't have enough information I
can do it again so here let's try to
find some moving averages so the 50-day
moving average seems to be acting as
support uh at least uh it acted on March
15th as support here a little bit as
resistance it's not perfect you see you
don't have anything very clean on the
stock like that that is moving that
strong it's not easy to find good levels
so I would say just roughly the 0.7
level user support next support upon 0.5
so just averaging down between 0.7 0.5
is a good strategy
um
you know the 20-day moving average was
acting as support it seems that it's
tested today uh
the level doesn't seem so bad the
question is can Bulls push higher again
I think they can okay but
I don't have any clear signal that booze
are going to take back control we have
an RSI above 50 on the daily time frame
so we can assume that
you know they're going to keep control a
little bit longer in the past usually
26th of August they were keeping control
for a few months so this is another
information we can use we can see that's
usually the bull cycles the bullish
Cycles last rather a month or two
uh than a week or two so it's been only
two weeks so we can expect maybe the end
of March to be bullish as well so you
know this is the type of things I can
say about CI all right
what else
okay
Market dropping
a little bit Triple Two minus one
percent
spy minus open three
AMC is still doing good
we like it
okay let me have a look at so nine I did
see I I did Andrew can you look at costs
yes brother from Korea if I remember
well let me have a look at that and hit
that like button guys 80 likes we can do
better than that
okay so cause
um
I don't know it's not the type of stocks
that um really
a big fan of
okay so what can we have here
so first weekly time frame okay
so this was it what a move
plus one thousand eight hundred percent
okay so this was a part of you know the
big rally we had on uh the meme stocks
in Jan okay memes uh on gme mostly but
it didn't squeeze in June afterwards it
went slightly higher and now it's
getting dumped uh okay the stock is
worth eight so it's not like really a
penny stock I mean the market cap let's
check the market cap I guess it's not
amazingly big but
let's check if I have some information
about the short interest
yeah I want to say guys bam
okay so mark
okay no options
no options and a very small shot it's in
the market cap is 77 million that's more
let me check that so because
let's check the market cap Gabrielle
coming back from the swimming pool guys
I'm gonna be there as well very soon
enjoy a little bit the sun in Panama so
market cap 77 million yeah that's
correct so cost Corporation designs
manufacturers and sells stereo
headphones all right audio video light
speakers and related accessory products
the company sells this product worldwide
under the cast brand name
okay
got it
they're not making money oh they're
making some money
but they have oppression and ratio at
400 all right so
so I think this is a promising company
that can you know do very well but in
the same time they are facing many
challenges so they can uh you know very
well have a hard time and I guess this
is all about that
uh
you know it's a meme stock typical
so small market caps so it's easy to
make it move if you know people start to
talk about it on social medias I guess
we can have some nice moves so let's
check if we have some early signs of
um reversal here so first on the weekly
time frame as you can see we add this is
the reason why I always have my moving
averages because the first thing I see
is that the 200 week moving average
acted very well as support recently then
we had to move up rejected on the
20-week moving average okay I'm just
taking information for now
then
what we're looking for as usual so then
we can check I'm still on a weekly time
frame we can check the volume so very
low volume and suddenly a big volume uh
this week so growing interest into the
stock all right but a big volume is good
but it's not enough for a reversal to
happen if you don't have a
a breakout together with it and for good
breakouts to happen you need to have a
nice consideration and you know to see
clearly where the booze where are the
beds
so what else do we have so yeah we have
a nice volume trading here
pretty interesting what I'm seeing
because I can already see the trendline
drawing and I uh okay so for now I'm
just doing this trend line so you can
see
no breakout of the last downtrend I have
on the daily timeframe no breakout right
and you can even see that
the rejection that happened here
probably happened because of Traders
using this trend line okay so first we
know that this trend line is followed uh
so we can keep it and it's going to be
useful for the future then
let's try to understand why we had this
big volume here so let's check first I I
guess there was a news right 22nd of
March uh you know it was just related to
the moves on AMC and Jimmy let's check
so this is see some checking cars
can you check if you have some news
about that
Benzie gas Daily Brief from 29 Game Stop
casting we don't know okay no okay it's
just because I think uh cast is
discussed on social media is like Reddit
you know YouTube Everything Discord and
you know there is just an interest of
investors in the stock but I don't see
any new news related to the companies
which I would have preferred to see
let's be honest because
um
that because it's you know most
sustainable to have a rally based on
some fundamental information rather than
based on a pump right so for now this is
a pump there is no other word to
quantify this move
and we are having a dump the question is
can we have another pump and yes I think
we can we have a quite nice support that
is created by this trend line that
created the strong move up okay once
again you can see
five seven reactions here two so this
consideration is not very nice but it's
still a small consideration indicating
that this trend line is followed and
then some move above this trend line so
right now we have some support
created at the
7.8 level
okay
so let's see what we do here
and chat so maybe we can set up a trade
on that I'm hesitating once again I want
to show you
you know I only take trades when I see
there is really your potential that the
risk reward is good here is not too bad
because we have the consolidation uh we
have big days happening on
um big volume days
happening on a Green Day so rules won
the day and then pull back on low volume
but here it would be anticipating a
breakout because as you can see we
didn't have a breakout so I prefer to
trade once I have the breakouts and to
buy the retest here I'm having early
signs of a breakout to come so it's not
enough for now to me to set up a trade
here
uh
if I had to maybe I will do it but maybe
not because once again it's not perfect
and I prefer to show you guys what is
good to do if I had to I would be a
buyer just above this level around 8.10
and I would stop loss just below this
consolidation that's why you need to
have those consolidation before breakout
um because you know that you have biased
them so you can just use a stop loss
just below this continuation
all right so uh by an 8.10 stop loss
seven it's tempting to put another here
I can put a small size I can you know
risk just one hundred dollars here
uh just for fun
the reason why okay but I will wait a
little bit
the reason why I could set up a trade
here is just because this red day here
minus nine percent happened on very low
volume very low volume so it means that
buyers didn't sell not a lot all of
buyers who bought here they didn't take
profits and we can have more buyers
getting in then we can also see that the
volume has still some room we've seen
much bigger volume training before this
stock has a history it starts to get
popular maybe on Reddit I don't know on
social medias let's have a look
afterwards on gme and AMC that are a bit
pulling back this was this is not bad
don't worry guys but this is a bit the
scenario we were filming today is that
Bulls don't manage to really push higher
with the momentum
uh let's see let's see if the day is not
over
I'm just coming back here quickly to
check if we don't want to make an order
here
but right now it's hard to buy okay even
my order at 140 I think I will cancel it
because
because we have a clear bearish
Divergence that is appearing on Jimmy
and you know we went close to the 160
level so somehow uh
I think that you know Bulls managed to
almost complete what they were targeting
which was the 160 level we almost
reached it so you know I don't see any
strong motivation right now from boost
to you know what is the next Target to
me like on the short term
to me it was 160 it it was almost Rich
so the only thing we could do in gym is
to you know buy 150 760 but is it really
what we are trying to do no we're trying
maybe to load shares at a better price
and you know get get uh this massive
third wave that would happen so it would
be happening later maybe at lower levels
uh so once again for just the day buying
150 could be done here because we can
see this is acting as support right now
148 is the level
it has been touched no right now guys
but let's
um but once again the here for now the I
see I see a little bit downside risk
coming for next week so I prefer for now
to just leave things as they are I will
seize an opportunity if I see really a
good one but once again for now I'm
happy with the my current position and
what I'm really targeting is the second
wave pullback to load some collapsions
at a good price uh maybe load more
shares we're gonna see if the volatility
is still high or not uh like you've
you've seen guys we are keeping an eye
on this AMC volatility is around 125 140
depending on the strike the maturity
let's check DME quickly so at least you
know we have some levels that we
remember
okay because when I used to work you
know in banking I was having a lot of
spreadsheet when I was recording all of
that and I could just go and you know
check that but it really takes a lot of
time so here I'm just gonna do it
sometimes and
um 200 I am too distracted uh
okay roughly the same levels guys you
see 120
on gme so this is the volatility price
so let's see if we have a second wife
pullback if we can buy some options at
110 volatility which would be much
better so this is what we're trying to
do guys
we once again today I don't want to rush
you know
um I don't see any obvious trade to do
this is not a good level for me to
increase the position for now unless we
take profits early but once again it's
not really the purpose of what is
happening here
um we could do that on any other stocks
guys so we're gonna have fun maybe you
know day trading other stocks but for
now the training games in Jimmy today is
not the best thing to do to me
unless we take you know short position
around 160 but it's not what I'm gonna
do for sure we are not here for that
so Bam Bam Bam let's get back to cuss I
was saying here yeah why not setting up
a bullish trade this could make sense
once again so I'm analyzing a little bit
more today we are damping
you see RSI that could once again you
can see guys this RSI 50 level is often
acting as support and resistance
on the RSI itself I mean not really
before June but after June here
resistance here resistance it's not
perfect but maybe huge is going to act
as support it's another information that
we can keep in mind okay
you see here RSI very strong then coming
back here and then acting as support
um
okay
so
here we have the 20-day moving average
as well coming here
okay
I'm keeping an eye on this it's not the
best setup I've seen for now I mean we
can do better than that let's wait a bit
let's not rush
which yeah Bitcoin is slightly pulling
back okay so what else you guys want to
see let me know
okay so see it's done because it's done
holding my 150 cool for June like it's
cold yeah I think the 150 strike yeah
but definitely it's a good strike I
guess you bought it uh with a good
timing bro so
very good position in the end of your
strike is low which is good once again
don't go to this very out of the money
options you know they are not good the
volatility is higher the Decay like
Theta is high as well uh it's better to
sell those options to buy shares sell
those very out of the money options that
trade at stupid prices
okay what do you think about PayPal
charts I had seen heavy bullish premium
flow in for April PayPal yay dropped
like a stone bro let's see what they are
doing now
okay so a little sign of recovery after
this massive move down guys
okay
I'll be back in two minutes guys
thank you
foreign
foreign
situation because we have a stock that
is definitely a very strong stock okay
you don't need to be a good in technical
analysis to see that I mean
the rally was just
amazing since 2015.
okay I don't have data before that not
sure they got listed here but whatever
so here
right now we're having
a massive correction pull back call it
whatever you want look at the red day
here the biggest volume ever
so I'm gonna have a look at the news I'm
not sure exactly what created that but
the first thing I do is I measure the
whole move up
and I apply FIB ratios
okay then I'm gonna check quickly the
news
what happened back then is is there a
very big news related to PayPal I think
that was the news so what day was that
on the
to the first of Jan let me check the
exact day
I'm gonna find that news quickly second
of Feb
yeah so we go I have here all the news
about PayPal news
that's the beauty of Bloomberg a bit
expensive though but a second of febs
okay so we have time can I filter that
okay it was here I saw it I went too
fast
okay okay so quarter quarterly results
sorry guys I'll scroll down too quickly
it should be clocked but I saw the news
it was correctly results
custom dates
and
okay
so this is the news PayPal plan just 22
at the up and after payment growth
slowed okay so it's really a news
related to the company uh fundamentals
so
um I don't have more information here I
could look for it but okay we just know
that there is something really related
to the Core Business of the company that
created this move down so it's not just
a pullback it is really a change
off I would say
you know even
long term
um you know business structure so
we can still use technical analysis of
course but we need to be aware that
after this news the levels we had here
that were not taking into account this
news are not going to be reached again
unless we have another news that cancels
this one okay it's some basic things but
it's important to remind you that so
that's why I checked if there was a news
really related to the company or not if
not then there is no reason we don't get
back there okay if we dropped for
technical reasons we're gonna go up
there for technical reasons as well but
when we drop
because of the fundamental news
um unless we have once again a news that
is canceling it you know even if it's
different
um we are not likely to go back there so
we can still do some TM and try to find
where are the support levels and
resistance levels the first thing what I
can tell you guys is that whenever you
drop below the 61.8 percent retracement
level uh you cannot consider we are
still bullish okay you need to
just be aware of the fact that
now we might just have a downtrend okay
the you know a correction deeper than
61.8 percent is not only a pullback is
really uh the beginning of something
especially involving that big volumes so
my first overall uh analysis in here is
that
there is no reason
to think a strong pullback will happen
Okay first
then we can still try to see where are
the resistance levels and the
um
support levels so I had here already the
support at 75 I had another one at
Knight C5 I'm not sure I had this one
before it was touched or not
because here we had some highs
probably I put it after it was touched
because otherwise I would have used this
low but right now I need to put it here
so the support levels are 95 70.5 are we
out of trouble is this move complete
I mean maybe
but maybe not so usually once again
a correction develops in three ways uh
an Impulse which is the beginning of
something develops in five waves so
let's try to count the waves here
so
I don't know if this is a one
uh you know I'd rather see something
like that guys okay
I rather see something like that just
because third waves are the ones
involving the most volume
uh so it looks like a third wave
uh then let's check if the force wave
pull back
is respecting some ratios okay it's very
weak so maybe we're gonna push higher to
the 130 level
but I doubt we really go above that
level
okay
here we have some resistances created by
description High
so here
the only strategy I would recommend not
Financial advice but it's to buy
the Deep first not by high because every
move that is going to be a bit too high
is going to be sold off guys in this
type of Market
uh so buying here seems even high to me
if we get back to 95 it's a nice
opportunity and keep some shares to add
more at 75. so buying between 75 and 95
is good and you can do better than that
and this is what I've been doing with
many stocks recently you can buy the dip
and
if you don't want to take profits early
because you think one day things can go
better fair enough but things will not
get better before June so you can sell
some cold options on June for example on
PayPal let me just show you how much you
can cash in by doing that uh you sell
the call options that you're gonna
you you choose the strike at the
resistance level because you know that
it's unlikely we break out Above This
resistance given the strong move down so
you can go to the 125 strike for example
and of course don't sell cool options
before buying puts but I'm showing you
if you buy 100 shares at let's say 95
all right
I like to sell twice the shares I buy so
you know I'm overselling on purpose
because I don't think the scenario is
likely to happen so on PayPal you go to
the 125 call and you sell if you buy 100
shares you sell two cool options okay
and let's see okay so basically you can
cash in for every 100 shares but you can
cash in 10 US Dollars all right so 1 000
US dollars that you're going to receive
on your account until June which is
basically making the same
um p l as if you bought your shares 10
points lower so if you get your shares
at 95 it's the same as getting it at 85.
you you follow me so here let me show
you the p l of the strategy
because I think we are in a type of
environment where uh investors will buy
the dip and sell the rip so you don't
want to
you you I mean we should not expect a
big rally happening on the global market
I think this year all right sorry for
being a little bit conservative about it
but we are as you guys know in a
situation that is not nice and you know
maybe things will go better maybe Putin
will become a nice guy and leave Ukraine
and things will go better and you know
inflation will drop Maybe
but maybe not so let's be prepared for
everything and I think that selling
calls if you buy the Jeep because let's
be honest there are many nice
opportunities this day and
myself I want to buy you know a lot of
you know stocks that seem undervalued
but fair enough I I bought some Baba
when it was dropping but I sold some
cool options right away I mean I waited
a little bit and on the first resistance
I sold the next resistance uh call
option which uh cash in for me 1 000 US
dollars in my Baba position and I did
that with many stocks and it's a good
strategy to make I'm showing you how it
looks
so if you do that
for example with PayPal okay so this is
the kind of money you can make so I
remind you we sell 100 shares
so let's say we buy it now because I use
Corruptions that are different price
okay or we we now we say we buy it lower
and I will just drop the volatility the
price action here
to get 10 percent
okay so if PayPal loses 15 percent
then we are at 95 so the call option is
much cheaper so then maybe we would go
to another one
uh
but let's still keep this example
and so basically you buy 100 shares at
95.
ideally you need to wait a little bit
before selling your cool option but
let's say you do it right away so You're
Gonna Save only 2.5 dollars per 100
shares boat which is not that much
because the volatility is only 45. you
can see here the wallet city is
extremely low amid
and I didn't have the okay because the
realized velocity is 67 but
the the volatility used by option market
makers at 45 so here it's good to buy
cool options actually so but whatever
I'm just showing you this strategy but
sure I wouldn't do it because the
volatility is very low and uh basically
you're gonna uh
so start losing money below to 92 and
you can make up to three thousand
dollars if PayPal closes at 125 which is
where you make the most money and then
you're gonna start slowly start to lose
the money you made and you're only gonna
lose money on this strategy if PayPal
goes above 160. so 160 guys is around
here uh I I don't think it can happen
before June okay maybe later but right
now the bearish momentum is very strong
and I don't see any reason unless there
is a news that best Let It Go and I
would personally hear you know be seller
between 125 and 170 if I if I was
working on you know this market and
selling stocks I would definitely sell
paper above 125. okay
so I'm done with paper
all right guys
so
so what is Gabriel trading today we have
a question
today not much I mean
um pretty pretty quiet I'm losing
basicism when I met yesterday so
yesterday I made 25k okay today I'm
losing 19. okay so what on oil I guess
uh remind us quickly your position
because maybe the viewers right now are
not the same as yesterday so what what
is your position just in the directional
because you have a lot of spreads we
know well it's uh mainly uh this is
basically indirectionally gonna be
mainly this gold versus silver okay uh
which today
um is not going in my direction but
actually it's good because I'm adding up
okay so his position is once again long
silver short gold because as we've seen
together before uh gold is ahead of
silvers gold is trading with a premium
compared to Silver exactly like gme
shredding with a premium compared to AMC
so whenever you you have something like
this with very correlated instruments
like mcgme or gold silver or we can find
many like that a good strategy is to
take the spread position because
ultimately the spread usually comes back
to what it should be okay sorry I let
you go to this uh I also have like just
silver long position okay and because
today like all the pressures have been
smashed I mean smashed what is silver
doing is not doing well okay and I
opened the position on Palladium on the
on the pullback okay but he actually
went further down so for now I'm losing
on my new position parallel okay but
Paradigm is very risky so I would not
advise okay to trade something but I
have to trade some quality which is like
you need to know what you're doing okay
okay okay so basically Gabrielle is long
silver
long silver shot gold long Palladium
long oil right yes the oil is I mean it
is up up now but I would say it's
flatish because
it was kind of down at the beginning of
the day now it's up so I mean not not
something yeah you know one person up
tremendous
yeah I agree okay so quiet day losing
20K
on a quiet day yeah guys I mean
sometimes really it's you know you need
to have solid nerves because this is a
quiet day and he's losing 20 cash so
sometimes it can go uh much lower than
that but of course most of the time it's
like plus 50 cat plus 16 plus 60k
sometimes he's doing 150 chain one day
so the purpose is to reach 5 million
dollars if I remember well yeah maybe
not this year but maybe not this year
guys so yeah when Gabriel will be at
five million dollars guys it's gonna be
uh
he's gonna be a good victory a big party
here guys all of you invited for sure
but we are not there yet and let's see
we let's see what's going to happen I'm
happy to be here you know he's showing
to me all the different strategies that
he likes to do I'm showing him like what
I like to do you know we exchange and
yeah it's very interesting so let's see
what's gonna happen in the future but
I like what what I see here
I mean on the other side it's something
completely apart yeah so I'm losing 20K
I mean 19k there but I'm making 80 on on
Arbitrage yes indeed because as you know
uh you know we are starting some nft
crypto bulls that are going to be based
on actually what Gabriel is doing and
he's you know basically making an
Arbitrage on the platforms for different
cryptocurrencies and this night
overnight he made 8 000 US Dollars by
doing nothing his boat is just running
and you know he managed to buy and sell
for big National can I say the national
uh I mean 250k okay I don't say the
cryptocurrency yeah
so so it's unfamiliar yeah
so he traded half a million of uh
cryptocurrency overnight I mean he's
bought traded for him and he locked in
8k of uh p l and we're gonna do that
with all the nft we're gonna have all
the cryptos nft holders we're gonna use
the money to run this Arbitrage if we
can because there are some issues with
the SEC and if we can and then we're
gonna give this money to the nft holders
or use it for some events or whatever
we're gonna do something big with that
and this is the reason why we call that
the crypto Bulls guys just one thing
because ATA compared to Alpha million
may look like you know small but it's
not like I have
much less but first is risk-free I buy
sell and I transfer so it's like the
national could is actually 20K of
national okay
yeah that's basically overall it's
making 8K okay
it's and it's not really overnight it's
more like around a 12 hour time frame
okay but because that sometimes
Arbitrage was so high
like 10 10 times the type of uh
yeah the type of profit you can make if
you do crypto Arbitrage sometimes you
have 10 difference in the price of the
same cryptocurrency across the platforms
but of course manually you cannot do
that and all the night doing that so you
need to use some Bots you need to know
how to do that and Gabrielle's knows how
to do it so thank you very much bro for
sharing that so yeah so what are you
checking today you're not taking the
spreads checking are you going to take
some trades or nothing much in the
weekend and then uh when you say I've
been I've been going to the pool I mean
at this point I don't really have uh you
know nothing nothing I don't really want
to add position right now because we
were kind of a in a kind of bull face
recently so now I'm just waiting for
some correction maybe to add more yeah
okay so you see Gabrielle is basically
doing the same thing as we do on AMC and
Jimmy he made some money on the way up
now he's thinking maybe a pullback is
gonna happen so as you can see right now
we dropped a little bit guys on AMC and
gme uh still up uh during the day but
you know we have this bullish bearish
Divergence we still had the increase in
volume but you know mixed signals the
best Divergence is winning for now
uh so yeah let's see what's gonna happen
guys
um
I'm Gonna Cancel my order for now that
is at
140 because we went to the Target and
after we reached the target uh it's not
a good buying Order anymore we should
have gone
you know lower first then higher then I
would be happy now that we reached 160
um I don't want to buy anymore I prefer
to wait for a nice opportunity to happen
um
okay so I'm gonna have a look at Gabriel
throw up exactly man
[Laughter]
you guys are funny
yeah yeah it's indeed a lot of pressure
and
he you need to have good nerves like I
said guys to handle this kind of p l and
you know positions so let me quickly go
back in your questions many questions
today thank you so much guys and hit
that like button once again guys it's
important for the channel and thank you
very much for asking that many questions
I'm sorry I cannot answer everyone uh
but it's it's good to see that you are
interested it's good to see that you are
here learning things enjoying this
so
do you think Chinese stocks like JD Baba
or Baidu are about to dump okay so I'm
gonna do I'm not gonna do technical
analysis about uh those Tech uh Chinese
Stacks but I can tell you one thing is
that I bought Baba you know on the dip
uh I took this risk
uh because
I mean it could have dumped more but I
would have kept it on the long run so my
cash would have been a bit stuck in
there right now we have our Chinese
government that said they would support
the market which means that they will
directly buy shares unofficially
unofficially because of course they are
not allowed to do that but you know the
people Bank of China which is the
Chinese Central Bank
they do that okay they will not say it
but they buy shares on the market Japan
at least they have the courage to say
they buy their ETF uh China is just
saying we're gonna support the market
but whatever the news is that they're
gonna support the markets but still you
need to know guys that China is not
happy with what is happening with all
this big Tech Chinese Tech uh why
because they have too much power a
company like Alibaba has so much
information about citizens
because you know they are doing many
businesses uh there's you know and they
are basically
um you know retrieving and keeping
records of transactions uh you know of
you know they have some social medias as
well uh and the Chinese government is
just seeing that those companies become
extremely strong a little bit like in
the U.S Facebook Google but the China is
not uh the United States right and even
in the United States The Regulators are
trying to control little bit that but in
China it's not the Chinese that they put
you down and they actually made it clear
when they uh told jackma who is the
owner I mean to create the the CEO and
uh get uh creator of Alibaba uh
billionaire Chinese billionaire and they
clearly put pressure on him and his
family uh his family is not allowed to
leave China if he does so they're always
going to keep you as you know hostage
somehow even if of course are not in a
jail or whatever and they they don't
hesitate to threaten you threaten your
family if you don't comply to the rules
and they clearly
um you know made it clear with Jackman
that disappeared for a few months we
don't know if he was kidnapped or just
asked to stay home he will not say what
happened he's doing good now we see him
again but they clearly told him that he
needs to be quiet and to respect the
rules and to do what the Chinese
government is telling him to do which is
complying with the rules
and basically China is not happy with
Alibaba having that much power with JD
having that much power with all this
Chinese Stacks so you know 10 cents most
likely as well so they're actually quite
happy to see the value dropping uh so
right now they're gonna sustain the
market but the fundamental issues which
are that China doesn't want this tech
companies to grow too big is still here
and it's not going to live so we have
this we have the U.S capital outflows
that happen because of the trade war
between China and U.S and we don't know
how China is going to be positioned
regarding the conflict with Russia so we
don't know
um if the U.S sanctions will not be
bigger next year so we have China that
is against its tech companies U.S that
is putting sanctions that impact China
uh so you know that's not very bullish
uh we also have the covet crisis that is
uh expanding again in China in Hong Kong
as well
so I don't think we're gonna have a big
rally coming this year I still bought
some babashes and I'm happy to keep it
but like I said I'm selling some calls
um I sold some 130 June calls and I'm
Gonna Roll this short call position uh
later if we drop I'm gonna sell a lower
strike because I don't think we are able
to revisit the highs uh just like for
PayPal guys I told you that whenever we
have some fundamental reasons to believe
a company value has dropped uh you know
for good reasons then there's not going
to be a strong bounce back unless we
have some good news so maybe China is
going to announce that uh right now they
won't you know Alibaba to be extremely
powerful but seriously I doubt it uh
maybe U.S sanctions are going to be
lower seriously I doubt it too
uh so I think we have at least a year
a six month where the Chinese market is
not going to drop more because once
again China is going to buy shares right
now so there is a flow we know the floor
the floor is roughly where it was
Alibaba but we could very well get back
to there and it would be another good
opportunity to buy not cool options once
again because I don't think we're going
to go very high but buy shares sell
calls all right so this is my view about
the Chinese text I hope I answered the
question well so are about to dump I
don't think they can dump much more I
think we can revisit the lows though but
it's it's gonna I don't think it can go
much lower of course only my view
okay
seems like spy headed to Max Payne
levels today it should be around four
four five levels
I don't think we go to four four five we
have no I think it's going to be a
boring day for spy you know even triple
choosing one percent is not a lot
uh I don't think much is gonna happen
here I think we're just gonna go to
maybe 446 like I said my view guys is
that we we Grant higher for the coming
week two weeks uh than correct and then
let's see what happens but I don't see
um I don't think we're gonna drop
heavily next week I think it's gonna be
a bit like you know lower volatility uh
lower volume just you know the Can
coming back and hopefully not before the
storm let's see guys
and cap
so SP so yeah 445 I have 445 is possible
sorry 445 is very possible to close the
day there why not why not
cost is Tiny okay Brandon not sure what
you mean but you mean the price is good
I guess
uh what is Cass doing we said maybe
we're gonna set up a trade there but the
setup was not perfect
yeah
it's tempting to buy it's tempting but
like once again I'm not in a rush
Bitcoin is correcting a bit
you see if Bitcoin comes back to 43 000
it could be a good level to buy
yesterday we set up an order on
um Vito so let's see if we are getting
close to this levels maybe we're going
to do this again
okay and come on guys we're almost at
100 likes
give me this thumb up
I'm using cause headphones now they're
good so you see okay the good good
things it's pretty nice
Okay so
let's quickly have a look at MC and
Jimmy yes because this is what why we're
here for then I'm gonna uh take back
your questions of course
so Bam Bam Bam Jimmy
okay we're just dropping a little bit
but
as you can see so let's go to 30 minutes
time frame
you see right now it's a bit too late to
set up an order here
okay first you don't want to buy a
moving average that is flattening okay
just like here I remind you guys we set
up a bullish trade around here I think
but do 20-day moving average was going
higher
we wanted to buy this morning around
this level around
140 we missed the trade because I was
too slow my bad but uh right now we
don't want to be using that anymore to
buy because you don't want to buy once
again using a moving average that is
flattening because uh the Star Plus
usually you place it just below and then
it's not going up with time so the risk
is not tightening which is the right
environment that you want to be trading
in
so here you know and if a moving average
that is flattening is the sign of bulls
you know losing strengths as well so
it's not Bully from the short term
okay
we can very well close at 160 today but
we won't go above that I think
let's see
I think that the second wave is going to
start next week and once again go to the
120 area that would be a very nice area
to buy on gme I had a question about AMC
I think as well
I forgot
Jimmy has a gap at 95. you think we can
fall there the next days no it seems too
far bus are too strong uh I mean we
cannot fall there just
here you mean 95
it's a little Gap
no where where do you see a gap
here
oh yeah but it's I don't know is it
really a gap then
yeah it's very little I don't think we
can go there no
not now maybe later
hopefully not but not right now Bulls
are too strong as you can see we
completed the one two three four five so
the worst case scenario right now of
course
you know there's no guarantee about
anything but you know 130 is the 38.2
percent FIB ratio uh in a bull run we
don't go below the 161.8 so between 110
and 130 to me is the worst case scenario
for now and then we're probably gonna go
get back to the 130 160 area later if we
drop that match if we drop only to 130
we're gonna get back there by next week
so we're gonna be here to buy 130 of
course
if we see this level
okay
so it's almost three hours I'm here good
luck Gabrielle yes thank you bro
Andrew's King thanks brother I'm glad
you like this guys
and by the way do not hesitate to follow
us on the crypto ball Discord guys
help us grow is going to be good for the
community good for all of you guys if
you're interested to get some uh crypto
booze nft of course you guys from the
Discord you're gonna access the private
cell which is even before the pre-sale
guys so we're gonna make some something
special for you so all of you guys who
are into nfts join us and
you we're gonna make it worth for you
trust me
chat and hit that like button yeah 100
likes that's good
yeah the Gap at 125 this one we can fill
it that's possible we need to see what
the moving averages will come we're
gonna see
okay bitcoin price so Bitcoin like I
said we have a breakout with that volume
so it can very well fade but it's still
interesting to take on to enter between
42 and 43 roughly and stop loss you know
around it's hard to use a stop loss here
but it's better so stop us around you
know fully
I don't know
there's not a nice area to
set up a stop loss but let's stop us
around 41. so you know this could be a
potential trade but it's not a very high
probability successful Trend because we
didn't have the volume during the
breakout if we push higher go to 50 46
000 on high volume then get rejected it
would be much easier to set up a
successful thread
okay guys so what else
what else all right okay
I do one more Jimmy do you still think
Jamie to 800 yes guys I still believe I
mean I need to refresh my targets it's
too early to say
um but if we start to squeeze I will
once again use the same techniques I
used before uh so I would measure you
know the first waves and try to predict
what is going to be the price of the
next one for now we having a first
impulsive wave so it's a good start
um
but we need more data to really give
precise targets I can still use what
happened last year but as you guys know
the more recent past is the more uh
important in terms of uh levels in terms
of
uh probability of success if you have
targets so let's wait but the area 800
135 is of course still in the menu
okay so Bam Bam Bam you're welcome
brother all right I do one more okay I
do Sophie and
and then I'll see you tomorrow guys so
Sophie
in case of dropping
I'm checking the volume dropping on low
volume so even the strong moves happen
on low volume so this is the first signs
that maybe bells are out of steam and
that may be a reversal is uh
is gonna happen soon so we then need to
look for reversal signs so here I'm
having a trendline that can do like that
so Sophie I would say anything below 11
is for now not strong enough uh and we
don't have any consolidation yet so we
have time there is no rush to do
anything here uh bang the Deep
seems risky because we are in you know
new we're making new lows so there is no
reason there is a rebound pass and
control they can push the price action
much lower if they want so I wouldn't
buy the Jeep I would wait some for for
some bullish signals okay guys so and
just last question about AMC I'm happy
to answer it can you take another look
at MC to see where it's going down today
okay
uh
so like I said it's hard to say but
we didn't have the fifth wave here
so I can use fibs on what happened
already and use the ratios to find some
first targets so giving it's giving me
18.95 which is in line with the 18.7 uh
level We're not gonna go there today I
think but it's a nice area to add more
shares next week if we see these levels
around 18.7 19 uh then another method I
can use is using some moving averages
but like I said I don't have any moving
average that is acting very well as
supports or resistance uh on AMC
so maybe the 50 on the 20 minutes time
frame which is right now giving us a
reaction at 20 we are right now at the
nice support level guys all right let's
be clear uh but we have weakness coming
from the volume less volume less
momentum so I mean it's just not the
best environment to buy you know I
bought before the third wave because
when you are before the show move up you
can expect a swimwear to happen once it
has it has happened you can expect one
more move but usually less stronger so
just in terms of risk reward it's not
the best day to buy AMC today
um on the long run is different I'm here
talking about you know today or next
week I think it's better to next connect
to wait for next week even buying
sometimes higher but with a higher
probability of success is better so it's
not only about I want to buy as low as
possible because by doing that you can
you know just buy something that is
dropping and that's you know never comes
back so I prefer to buy whenever I have
good
uh patterns oh right and then 18.7 yeah
so this is what I I can say all right
thank you very much guys for watching uh
for those who didn't press the like
button do it now before going and the
weekend is coming so I'm gonna you know
enjoy my time here maybe I'm gonna do a
video during the weekend uh if you know
I have some time but most likely you're
gonna see me back on Monday guys so have
a very good weekend thank you again for
watching and stay close to show of
course see you guys